Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode 24. Some JVM languages, Jython, Clojure, and Scala. Take it away, Jason. Hey, how's it going, everybody? We're back. Longest episode title so far. Yeah, yeah, that's what we're going for. We're breaking records left and right. So yeah, we actually, you know, I think it's been a little while since we did a programming
由 Host Tornado 提供托管服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 24 期。一些 JVM 语言：Jython、Clojure 和 Scala。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？我们回来了。这是目前为止最长的剧集标题。没错，没错，这就是我们的目标。我们正在不断打破纪录。所以，是的，我们实际上，你知道，我觉得我们已经有一段时间没有做编程语言节目了，因为，你知道，我们之前做了邮件问答，然后又聊了 Hadoop 框架，所以能涵盖三种语言来弥补这一点真的很酷，这就像是一套组合拳，随你怎么说，但请在最后再下定论。我们实际上有一个来自听众 Roger 的问题，想用它来开启今天的节目。我们有听众，我们确实有听众。其实，我们知道有 Roger。我不知道我们是否有听众。不，我们有的。我们收到了一些忠实听众的电子邮件。不，是的，我们绝对，
language show because, you know, we had the mailbag and then we had uh you know the hadoop framework and so it's pretty cool we're actually gonna cover three languages make up for it it hits you with yeah sure one two three punch combos say what you want but uh save judgment until the end we have a question from uh roger actually out in the audience that we wanted to kick off the show with we have an audience we have an audience actually We have an audience. Actually, well, we know we have Roger. I don't know if we have an audience. No, we do. We get email from a couple of loyal listeners. No, yeah, we definitely,
我们绝对感谢这些电子邮件提问。还有评论，我们在 G Plus 帖子上的评论之类的。是的，完全正确。很高兴看到社区依然活跃、繁荣。也感谢大家查看这些书籍，以及所有那些好东西，还有节目中提到的工具，希望我们能继续，你知道，为大家提供一些专家建议。
and we definitely appreciate the email questions. And comments, comments on our G Plus posts and stuff. Yeah, totally. It's good to see the community's living, thriving. Thanks for checking out the books, too, and all that good stuff, and the tools of the show, and hope that we can keep, you know, giving you guys some, some expert advice.
一定是新年到了。你听起来非常，呃，有见地。就像你一直在思考这个问题一样。是的。我的意思是，我整个圣诞假期都在反思。好吧。总之，Roger。好的。
It must be the new year. You sound very, uh, insightful. Like you've been thinking about this or something. Yeah. I mean, I had that whole, like, you know, Christmas break to just kind of reflect and. Okay. Anyways, Roger. All right.
所以 Roger 有个问题。他的问题是，你们有没有觉得工作跟不上？例如，我的工作是使用 C 和 Java 编程，但最近我觉得自己落后于整个 Web 运动。我尝试做一些副业项目来跟上进度。我先来回答这个问题。这容易吗？是的。是的，你会有很多这种感觉。
So Roger had a question. His question is, do you guys ever feel behind in work? For example, I have a job where I code in C and Java, but lately I feel like I'm falling behind the whole web movement. I try to work on side projects to help keep up. So I'll take first stab at this. Is it easy? Yes. Yes, you feel a lot.
好吧，他说他从没觉得落后。是的。好吧，就是这样，Roger。是的。所以有几种方法可以理解 Roger 在这里所说的。但是，我的意思是，首先我们所有人都非常、非常忙。而且，你知道，这通常就是个笑话，对吧？这是一件好事。
Well, he said he's never felt behind. Yes. Okay. Well, there you go, Roger. Yes. So there's a couple ways to kind of, I mean, guess at what Roger is saying here. But, I mean, first is we all are very, very busy. And, you know, often that's kind of the joke, right? It's a good thing.
如果你不忙，你才应该感到害怕，对吧？是的，完全正确。你可能在那家公司待不了多久了。所以忙碌是非常正常的。这很好。而且，我的意思是，我们工作在一个人们不一定
If you weren't busy, you should be scared, right? Yeah, totally. You might not be working at that place for much longer. So being busy is, like, very, like, normal. It's good. And then also, I mean, we work in a world where people don't necessarily
了解编程的世界里。我们很多人为那些不是工程师、不是技术人员或程序员的人工作，因为他们很难理解我们那种工作流程。而且即使你确实为这些人工作，
understand programming. So many of us work for people who aren't engineers or technical or programmers because they have a very hard time understanding that kind of workflow that we have. And then even if you do work
软件工程仍然相对较新。所以关于估算某件事需要多长时间以及投入多少人力的想法，我们仍然不太擅长。是的，而且一切都太新、太不同了，你不知道会遇到什么障碍，所以你经常会发现自己在工作中超负荷。我的意思是，这很常见。是的，而且很多人，你知道，觉得“哦，我正在为这个摩托罗拉芯片编写汇编代码，用来驱动交通灯之类的东西”，就像“我应该在 Web 上使用一些疯狂的高级语言做些事情，还有所有这些大数据，我听说那是最新的东西”，诸如此类。所以，你知道，我认为深入钻研技术是有意义的，即使这项技术不是最新、最伟大的东西，你仍然可以在你正在做的事情上获得很多经验，而且那里仍然有很多价值，对吧？所以你不应该太担心“哦，我没有做我在新闻里读到的最新东西”，
for those people, engineering, software engineering is still relatively new. So this whole idea of estimating how much stuff should take and how many people to put on something we're just still not really that good at yeah and so and everything is so new and different and you don't know what obstacles you can run into so often you find yourself overloaded at work i mean this is very common yeah and i mean a lot of people you know feel like oh i'm coding in like assembly for
因为最新东西会变老。要么最新东西会变老，要么它会消亡，对吧？这两者中的任何一个都很好。所以，总的来说，有这个。那很深刻，Jason。但是，是的，我的意思是，我认为他的观点，也非常中肯，就是继续做副业项目并保持与时俱进。但很难找到时间。
this motorola chip for the to power a traffic light or something like that it's like i should be working on like doing stuff in the web using some crazy high level language and all these things and big data i'm hearing that's the latest thing and all that and so you know i think that there is something to be said for sort of just really diving deep into technology even if that technology isn't the latest greatest thing you could still get have a lot of experience just on you know something that you're working on now and uh there's still a lot of value there right so you shouldn't worry so much about oh i'm not doing the latest thing right that i'm reading about in
你有生活。你有工作。所以你可能会像我讨论的那样在工作中感到不知所措，感觉很糟糕，没有时间做其他事情。或者反过来，Jason 对这种“感觉落后”以及“你没有在做最新、最伟大的东西”的解读。但我的意思是，在大多数情况下，情况总是这样。
the news because the latest thing will will get old either the latest thing, right, that I'm reading about in the news because the latest thing will get old. Either the latest thing will get old or it will die, right? Either of those two are very good. So, you know, in general, there's this. That was deep. That was deep, Jason. But, yeah, I mean, I think that his point, which is very salient too, is just to continue to do side projects and keep yourself up to date. But it's hard to find time with that.
有些公司会选择一种东西并坚持使用它。所以即使你在那家尖端公司工作，做着尖端的事情，很可能在两、三、四、五年后，那个东西就成了每个人都在使用的成熟、安全的项目，对吧？如果你总是必须做尖端的东西，那将是一件危险的事情。所以我确实认为进行一定程度的副业项目、阅读、观看 YouTube 视频或尝试学习新语言，无论是什么，都是很重要的，
You have life. You have work. So you can be overwhelmed at work like I was discussing and just feel bad and not have time for the other stuff. Or even the other way, Jason's interpretation of this like feeling behind and that you're not working on the latest and greatest. But I mean for the most part that's always going to be the case.
你知道，尝试刺激一下，让你的大脑保持工作和学习。是的。我的意思是，就像现在，至少从我读到的来看，Ruby on Rails 就像是一个大热词，你知道，它是热门的东西。伙计，我觉得那是几年前的事了。现在什么才是热门的？我觉得，我的意思是，它甚至超过了 Node.js，然后现在连那个也有一两年了。所以它甚至超过了那个。天哪，我落后了。我，我想，实际上我的想法，它不完全一样，对吧？但我的意思是，热词一直在变，我的意思是，总会有新的东西。是的，是的，那个
Some companies kind of pick a thing and stick with it. And so even if you worked on that cutting edge company, working on that cutting edge thing, likely in two, three, four, five years, that thing is now the mature, safe project that everybody's using, right? And you would have to like, this would be a dangerous thing if you always had to work on the cutting edge thing. So I do think it is important to have some level of side projects or reading or watching YouTube videos or trying to just learn new language, whatever it is,
地平线，我觉得我大概落后了三到五年。好吧，我可能比那还要远。我只是知道它们是什么。我完全不知道怎么做。但是的，我的意思是，了解最新、最伟大的东西是好的，拥有这种广度是好的，但这不是真正需要担心的事情。就像 Patrick 说的，有……那么如果他还在用 COBOL 编程呢？如果他还在用 COBOL 编程？
you know, to try to stimulate that, you know, keep your brain working and learning. Yeah. I mean, like right now, at least from what I've been reading, Ruby on Rails is kind of like the big buzzword, you know, it's like the hot thing. Dude, I think that was like years ago. What's the hot thing now? I think like, I mean, it's even passes like to Node.js and then now even that's a year or two old. So it's even past that. Oh man, I'm falling behind. I i think i think actually my song it's not exactly the same right but i mean like the buzzwords keep like i mean it's always going to be something new yeah yeah and that
好吧，他很好，他在看节目或听节目。这有一个限度，对吧？所以如果语言……无论什么，你知道，我们不知道具体情况，你只需要尽力而为。我们理解你，我们理解你所处的痛苦，但我的意思是，你必须，如果你使用的语言……COBOL 没什么错，你知道，做那些使用 COBOL 编程的工作肯定能赚很多钱。
horizon i think i'm about three to five years behind okay like i'm probably farther than that i just know what they are i have no idea how to do them but yeah i mean you know you know knowing about the latest and greatest thing is good and having that breadth is good, but it's not something to really worry about. And like Patrick said, there's... So what if he's still programming in COBOL? If he's still programming
是的，但有一种平衡，比如了解你正在承担的风险和事情，如果你使用的语言或环境仍然被更新的东西所使用，那么你可能就没问题。所以像 Java、C++，甚至 C，对吧？这些东西今天仍然被积极使用。所以这仍然是一个肥沃的领域，你不应该太害怕。
in COBOL? Well, he's good he's watching the show or listening to the show. And there's a limit to it, right? So if the language... With anything, you you know we don't know the situation you just got to do the best you can we we feel you we understand the pain you're in but i mean you gotta kind of if you're using a language that nothing wrong with coldball there's you know lots of good money i'm sure to be made working jobs where you program in coldball
但如果你所处的东西基本上全是维护工作，那很危险，因为如果你知道，那是你的专长，并且你愿意拥抱它，那很好；否则，那些仍然在使用它的项目数量会越来越少。是的，所以这有风险。而且你也不会学到如何编写全新的东西，因为你一直被困在维护中。是的，是的。为了回应 Patrick 的观点，换一种说法，这真的取决于你在做什么，而不是语言，对吧？我的意思是，你可以做，所以我做了很多 C++，而 C++ 并不是最新、最性感的
yeah but there's a balance of like you know understanding what risks and things you're taking on and if you're working in a language or environment that is still being used by newer stuff, then you're probably pretty much okay. So things like Java, C++, even C, right? These things are still being used actively today. So that's still a fertile field and you shouldn't be too scared.
语言，但我感觉我正在做的事情相当新颖且有趣，对吧？所以这才是你应该寻找的东西。等等，但刚刚出现了 C++ OX，对吧？它刚刚，它是新的，对吧？是的，所以这才是你应该寻找的东西。DAN GALPINIUK, JR.：等等，但刚刚出现了 C++ OX，对吧？它刚刚变得新了，对吧？DAN GALPINIUK, JR.：是的，我们还没有转向那个。实际上，我收回前言。我认为 C++ OX 是受支持的，但我还不知道它。所以我知道一些事情，但没什么大不了的。
But if you are on something that basically it's all maintenance all the time that's dangerous because if you know and that's like your thing and you're going to embrace it great but otherwise those number of projects still on that are going to get smaller and smaller to some level yeah so that's risky and then also you don't learn that how to kind of code brand new things because you're just stuck in maintenance all the time. Yeah, yeah. And to Patrick's point, just to say it a different way, it really depends on what you're working on much more than the language, right? I mean, you could be doing, so I do a lot of C++, and C++ isn't like the newest, sexiest
但是的，回应 Patrick 的观点，如果你对自己的工作感到满意，并且正在做一些有趣、有意义的事情，那才是最重要的。你正在做副业项目很好，这样如果工作对你来说变得乏味，你就可以去尝试，并且你会有最新的技术傍身。进入我们的新闻环节，上周是消费电子展 (CES)。所以我们录制节目到发布之间有一点延迟。但我们觉得这个讨论仍然会很有趣。是的。有一堆新产品，让你花掉你辛苦赚来的钱，
language, but I feel like I'm working on something that is pretty new and interesting, right? And so that's really the thing you should look for. Wait, but there just became like C++ OX, right? It just like, it's new, right? Yeah so that's really the thing you should look for. DAN GALPINIUK, JR.: Wait, but there just became C++ OX, right? It just like gets new, right? DAN GALPINIUK, JR.: Yeah, we haven't moved to that yet. Actually, I take it back. I think C++ OX is supported, but I don't know it yet. So I know a few things, but nothing too big.
在你编写编程语言的同时。就像，一年后你要把它们花在什么上，对吧？所以这就是 CES 会向你展示的。有各种各样的公告。但我想要挑选几个，因为它延续了一条线索，我想这条线索在我们的许多节目中都出现过，我们一直有兴趣讨论
But yeah, to Patrick's point, if you're happy with your job and you're doing some fun, interesting things, that's really what matters. And it's good that you're doing the side projects so that if the job does get stale for you, you can go and you'll have the latest tech under your belt. Moving on to our news, last week was the Consumer Electronics Show. So we have a little bit of delay from when we record this to when we release it. But we feel like this discussion will still be interesting. Yeah. There was a bunch of new products, things for you to spend all of that hard-earned money that you're making
像新主机和 Ouya 之类的东西，虽然有一些关于 Ouya 的消息出来，但有几家大公司，它们传统上并不以做主机或便携式游戏设备而闻名，也发布了相关公告。第一个传闻已久，但 Steam 终于确认他们一直在与硬件制造商密切合作，
while writing in your programming languages. Like, what are you going to spend them on in another year, right? So that's what CES will show you. There's all sorts of new announcements. But I wanted to pick up on a couple because it kind of carries forward a thread that I guess has been in many of our shows and we've been interested in talking about
发布人们一直称之为 Steam Box 的产品。这是一种运行 Steam 游戏的硬件。我想其中一个叫 Piston，我看了 Steam 那位负责人的采访，他说他们实际上计划了一整套产品系列。
with things like the new consoles and the Ouya and these kind of things, which there was some stuff about Ouya came out, but there was a couple of big name companies which aren't traditionally known for doing console or portable gaming stuff had announcements about that and the first one has been rumored for a long time but Steam finally confirmed that they've been working closely
就像他们设想的一整套东西。有些很酷。有些有点疯狂和离谱。但绝对听起来很有趣，因为这将是下一代 Xbox 和下一代 PlayStation 的直接竞争对手。我不知道。它可能已经超过了 Wii U。我不知道 PlayStation 的竞争对手……是的。我不知道。
with a hardware manufacturer to release what people have been calling the Steam Box. This is a hardware that will run Steam games. I guess one of them is called Piston and I watched an interview with the guy from Steam and he was saying that there's actually a whole family of products they have planned.
它可能已经超过了 Wii U。我不知道 Wii U 的竞争对手……不，我开玩笑的。我对 Wii U 一无所知。它已经有两倍的规格之类的了。所以，但是，是的，但是，我的意思是，它将能够运行——所以 Steam 的官方版本或他们的合作版本或他们的——我不知道这是否会像谷歌对安卓手机所做的那样。他们有一个 Nexus。也许 Steam 会有一种“这是我们当前认可的平台”的感觉。
Kind of like a whole change of things that they have envisioned. Some of it is pretty cool. Some of it's kind of crazy and out there. But definitely sounds interesting because this is going to be a direct competitor to whatever the next Xbox and next PlayStation. I don't know. It'll already probably be surpassing the Wii U. I don't know how much of a PlayStation. Yeah. I don't know.
我的意思是，没有太多细节流出。但他确实说 Steam 的那个将运行 Linux，并且它将运行所有当前的 Steam 游戏。所以，如果你有 Steam，他们必须引入这个大屏幕模式。哦，是的。我见过那个。所以你可以把它连接到你的电视上运行。然后他说他们真的专注于
It'll already probably be surpassing the Wii U. I don't know how much of a competitor the Wii – no, I'm just kidding. I don't know anything about the Wii U. It already has twice the specs or whatever. So, but, yeah, but, I mean, it's going to be able to run – it's so Steam's official version or their partnered version or their – I don't know if this will be maybe like Google does with the Android phones. They have, like, a Nexus. Maybe Steam will have kind of like this is our current endorsed platform.
做一些非常棒的外设。比如控制器之类的，延迟非常低。哦，像《吉他英雄》的吉他吗？不，我不觉得是那样。所以他实际上是在说新趋势是转向 Wii U、Kinect 和 PlayStation Move，所有这些东西。他说那些，如果你仔细想想，
I mean, not a ton of details are out. But he said the Steam one is going to run Linux, and it's going to run all the current Steam games. So, like, if you have Steam, they have to introduce this big screen mode. Oh, yeah. I've seen that. So you'll be able to hook it up to your TV and run it. And then they're really focusing, he said,
是对系统的低带宽输入。所以你必须挥动你的手臂或跳舞。但如果你试图做精确的动作，这真的很难。他说，所以为什么要担心那个？别担心。他把那些东西称为一种时尚。啊，我明白了。所以他说他想制造一种无线控制器，
on doing some really awesome peripherals. So controllers and stuff that have really low latency. Oh, like the guitar for Guitar Hero. No, I don't think like that. So he's actually kind of saying the new thing is to move into, for the Wii U and Kinect and the PlayStation Move, all these things. He said those are, if you think about it,
延迟非常、非常低，而且非常精确，工作起来非常好。这让我觉得主机时代要终结了。我的意思是，为什么 PlayStation 在必须与 Steam 竞争时还要制造 PS4，因为 Steam 拥有所有的 PC 用户？但也许我在想我们正在走向一种混合方法。哦，因为这是一个主机。
really low bandwidth input to the system. So you have to wiggle your arms around or do a dance. But it's really hard, especially if you're trying to do precise movements. He's like, so why worry about that? Like, don't. He kind of called that stuff a fad. Ah, I see. And so he's saying he wants to make a wireless control
COLTON OGDEN：“是的，它是一个主机。它是一个盒子。你买它。你不组装它。你不会去找戴尔然后运行 Windows。我的意思是，在大多数情况下，会有人控制它端到端的东西，这就是主机的本质，对吧？
that's really, really low latency and really precise and just works really well. It makes me think the console era is going to die. I mean, why would PlayStation make a PS4 when they have to compete with Steam, which gets all the PC users? But maybe I'm thinking we're going to more a hybrid approach. Oh, because this is a console.
DAN GALPIN：“是的，我想这是真的。主机和 PC 之间唯一的区别在于 PC 对用户有不同的期望。比如你被期望升级操作系统之类的。但我的意思是，这个东西确实模糊了界限，我的意思是，如果他们有自己的操作系统，他们会保持更新之类的，而你只是在上面玩游戏，
COLTON OGDEN:" Yeah, it is a console. It's a box. You buy. You don't build. You don't go to Dell and run Windows. I mean, for the most part, there's going to be someone controlling pretty much the end-to-end kind of stuff on it, which is the nature of the console, right?
并且你没有 root 权限之类的，那么我想它在技术上就是一个主机，即使它实际上运行的是 Linux。DAN GALPIN- 是的，所以这会很有趣。这将是激动人心的时刻。但我认为这很酷。而且你还对生物识别作为输入发表了一些评论。所以我开始和一些朋友推测
DAN GALPIN:" Yeah, I guess it's true. Really, the only difference between a console and a PC is that a PC has different expectations for the user. Like you're expected to upgrade the OS and things like that. But I mean, this thing which really blurs the lines, I mean, if they have their own OS that they keep up to date and things like that, and you just play the games on it,
会有什么样的东西。我想到了一个，所以你必须让我知道你对此有什么看法。他们有皮肤电反应的想法。这是你皮肤的导电性。所以它会随着压力而改变。所以如果你做测谎仪测试，我从来没做过测谎仪测试，
and you don't have root access or whatever, then I guess it's technically a console, even though it runs effectively like Linux. DAN GALPIN- Yeah, so it'll be interesting to see. There's going to be interesting times. But I thought it was kind of cool. And you also had some comments about biometrics as inputs. And so I started kind of speculating with some friends
但他们测量的事情之一就是这个。所以众所周知，如果你感到压力，我想你的皮肤开始出汗。所以盐是导电的。所以你的皮肤变得更导电。类似那样。我不知道。这有点像，
like what kind of stuff. And one thing I thought of, so you have to let me know what you think about this. So they have this idea of the galvanic skin response. This is the conductivity of your skin. So it changes in response to stress. So if you do a lie detector test, I've never done a lie detector test,
我可能完全搞错了。这说得通。但如果你能测量某人有多大压力，想想那些很酷的事情。所以我们从这个开始。有什么酷的游戏点子？我们想到的一个是，如果你有一个恐怖游戏，如果你压力太大，那么本质上你就会输。
but one of the things they measure is this thing. So it's known like if you get stressed out, I guess your skin starts to kind of sweat. And so salt is conductive. So your skin becomes more conductive. Something like that. I have no idea. This is kind of like,
所以你必须做非常……比如剪掉炸弹上的电线。但如果你对它感到太紧张和焦虑，炸弹就会爆炸。对吧？所以好吧。这就像一场瞪眼比赛。你进行瞪眼比赛。这是来自柯南·奥布莱恩 (Conan O'Brien)。
I probably got this completely wrong. That makes sense. But so if you could measure how stressed somebody was, think about just cool things. So we started with this. What kind of cool game ideas? So we thought of one was if you had a horror game, and if you got too stressed, then essentially you would lose.
这是他和联合主持人 Andy 做的短剧，他们互相盯着看。然后柯南头后面会发生疯狂的事情，他看不到，但另一个人能看到。人们会半裸着跑出来之类的，然后最终那个人会输，因为会发生太疯狂的事情。你完全可以这样做。你盯着屏幕，它只是向你展示越来越多的疯狂。
So you had to do really like, like cutting wires on a bomb. But if you got too stressed and nervous about it, the bomb would just blow up. Right? So okay. It's like a staring contest. You do the staring contest. And this is from Conan O'Brien.
然后它向你展示高达风格，你就像，手变得非常出汗。但同样有趣的是，即使是像，你知道，当然是在用户披露或其他什么的情况下，如果你甚至只是在测试一个游戏，看看哪些部分让人们压力最大，以便你可以优化它，那也会很有趣。甚至游戏可以学习什么最让你感到压力，
It was a skit he did with Andy, the co-host, where they would stare at each other. And then like crazy things would happen behind Conan's head where he couldn't see it, but the other guy could. And people would run out half naked and all that stuff, and then eventually the guy would lose because something so crazy would happen. You could totally do this. You stare at the screen, it just shows you more and more craziness.
比如一个家伙从拐角处跳出来，或者像走廊里一个非常巨大的、笨重的家伙。慢僵尸还是快僵尸？你知道，哪些真的让你受不了？然后游戏可以几乎像，你知道，根据你最害怕或最不害怕的东西来量身定制。比如你压力很大，所以它停止做那些事情，因为它试图成为一种愉快的体验。是的，是的。那很酷。
Then it shows you Gundam style, and you're like, hands get really sweaty. But also interesting would be even as like, you know, of course with user disclosure or whatever, but it'd be interesting if you're even just testing a game to see what parts are making people most stressed so you could optimize it. Or even the game could learn what stresses you the most,
我不知道。我的头在旋转，但那是我们进行的一次疯狂对话。这太棒了。所以 NVIDIA 还有其他文章，它是一个便携式手持 PC，呃，看起来很酷，嗯，看起来是 NVIDIA Shield，Project Shield，是的，Project Shield，它就像一个控制器，然后它看起来就像你拿着一个控制器，就是这样。但控制器的顶部实际上可以翻开，有点像翻盖手机，有一个屏幕，就是这样。但控制器的顶部实际上可以翻开，有点像翻盖手机。
like a guy popping around a corner or like a really huge, you know, lumbering guy down the hall. Slow zombies or fast zombies? You know, which ones really get to you? And then the game could kind of almost like, you know, tailor itself to what you're most scared or least scared. Like you're really stressed, so it stops doing those things because it's trying to be a pleasant experience. Yeah, yeah. That's pretty cool.
而且有一个屏幕。所以仅仅通过拥有一个实际上能放进你口袋的东西，你就可以玩所有这些游戏。SETH LADDESCHERRERA- 所以这是一个安卓手持设备。但它不是手机或平板电脑，我的意思是，它是为了游戏而设计的。它是一个游戏控制器。这就是它的外形。
I don't know. My head was spinning, but that was one crazy conversation we had. That's totally awesome. So there's other articles on the NVIDIA it's a portable handheld pc and uh it looks pretty cool um it looks it's nvidia shield project shield yeah project shield it's like a controller and then it it looks it looks like you're holding a controller and that's it but the top of the controller actually flips open kind of like a flip phone and there's a screen and that's it. But the top of the controller actually flips open, kind of like a flip phone.
但他们正在用它做一些非常聪明的事情。首先，平台非常强大，所以你可以在上面玩非常好的安卓游戏。但随后他们引入了与此相关的概念，即从你的 PC 流式传输游戏。所以你可以在我家，比如，楼上，运行一台 PC，他们也谈到了 Steam 游戏。你实际上可以，你知道，
And there's a screen. And so just by having something that effectively fits in your pocket, you can play all of these games. SETH LADDESCHERRERA- So this is an Android handheld. But instead of being a phone or tablet, I mean, it's meant for gaming. It is a game controller. That's the form factor there.
你的输入会传到那个东西，然后你的，传到那台电脑，然后那台电脑也会把视频流回你的设备，如果你有合适的显卡的话。这有点像那个云端的东西。所以是的，它完全是在线的。所以它就像在线，但区别在于你不需要去云端。
But they're doing some really clever stuff with it. So first of all, the platform is pretty powerful, so you can play really good Android games on it. But then they introduced, related to this, this concept of streaming the games from your PC. So you could have a PC in my house, like, upstairs, running, and they also talked about Steam games. And you can actually, you know,
它就在你家里。对，对。所以处理是在本地进行的，他们展示的演示，它实际上是通过以太网连接的。他们说是因为那是一个嘈杂的 Wi-Fi 环境。但他们设想这个工作得很好。这有多酷？你经常试图在楼下，只是做别的事情。你不想去坐在你的电脑前，至少对我来说，这有点像在那段时间里不允许其他人与你互动。
your input would go to that thing and then your, go to that computer and then that computer would also stream the video back to your device if you had the right video card for it. It's kind of like that cloud thing. So yeah, it's exactly on live. So it's just like online, but the difference is you don't go to the cloud.
你有点在做你自己的事情。你在电脑上。但如果你能坐在沙发上拿着一个小手持设备，对吧，只是玩玩，那会很酷。是的，这超级有趣。它也能当手机用吗，还是不能？哦，我不知道。哦，好吧。
It's in your house. Right, right. So like the processing is local and the demo they were showing, it was actually hooked up over Ethernet. And they were saying because it was a noisy Wi-Fi environment. But they envisioned this working really well. And how cool is that? How often you're trying to be downstairs, just doing something else. You don't want to go sit at your computer where, at least for me, it's kind of like nobody else is allowed to interact with
我没读过，但我不这么认为。是的，它看起来不像有接收器之类的东西。所以我认为这非常有趣，然后他们结合 Steam Box 谈到了这一点，对吧？所以如果你想想这个，如果你把这一套组合拳配对，那么它基本上就像一个 Wii U，但是，但我实际上想要一个，两者都想要，而不是像 Wii U 那样完全没有拥有的欲望。
you during that time. You're kind of doing your thing. You're on the computer. But if you could sit there with a little handheld on the couch, right, and just kind of playing around, that would be really cool. Yeah, this is super fun. And does it work as a phone, too, or no? Oh, I don't know. Oh, okay.
是的，完全正确，这太棒了。所以我的意思是，即使从这个无线设备，如果 NVIDIA 做得好？而且这是其他人已经开始做的事情。我觉得这将是今年或明年一个巨大的、新的东西。就像你在 Apple 设备上有 AirPlay 一样。所以你有连接到电视的 Apple TV，连接到电视的 Apple TV，它实际上变成了一个显示器。
I didn't read, but I wouldn't think so. Yeah, it doesn't look like it has a receiver or anything like that. So I thought this was really interesting, and then they talked about this in combination with the Steam Box, right? So if you think about this, like if you pair this one two punch thing right then it's basically like a wii u but like but i actually want one both of them as opposed to the way you have no desire
然后你可以镜像 iPad 或 iPhone 上的内容。安卓，你知道，我敢肯定，也有类似的东西。他们会有那个。这几乎达到了同样的效果。如果你有这个控制器和一些我可以插到电视上的棒，然后我所有的设备都可以和它对话，这个，我不知道。那会非常棒。
to own yeah exactly this is pretty awesome so i mean that but and then even from this wireless device if if you had if nvidia did this well? And it's what others are already starting to do. And I feel like this is going to be a huge, like new thing this year or next year. It's like you have like AirPlay on the, you know, Apple devices. So you have the Apple TV hooked up to your TV, the Apple TV hooked up to your TV, which effectively becomes a monitor.
这实际上让我很兴奋。我很想拥有。另一件事是，我很想有派对游戏，人们可以过来带上他们的控制器，你就可以，比如，因为这个控制器实际上有一个屏幕。所以你可以做一些事情，比如你可以玩五张牌梭哈扑克，你的牌会在你的手上。或者琐事。
And then you can mirror what's on your iPad or iPhone. Android, you know, I'm sure, has got something similar. They're going to have that. This gets to almost the same thing. If you have this controller and some stick that I can plug into my TV, and then all my devices can talk to it, this, I don't know. It'd be totally awesome.
想想琐事游戏。是的。就像人们拿出他们的 iPhone 或安卓手机，对吧，你只是，你知道，抢答，或者你有这个。是的。那会超级棒。非常棒。我不知道。
This actually makes me excited. I would love to have. The other thing, too, is I would love to have party games where just people could come over and bring their controller, and you could just do, like, because this controller actually has a screen. So you could do things like you could play, like, five-card stud poker, and your cards would be on your hand. Or trivia.
所以也许我对此有点太兴奋了。不，不，我觉得这个。是的。那会超级棒。非常棒。我不知道。所以也许我对此有点太兴奋了。不，不，我觉得这很棒。我觉得这超级酷。你现在能买到一个吗，还是不能？不能。哦，还没。这个东西在不久的将来会出来。
Think about, like, a trivia game. Yeah. Like, just people pull out their iPhones or Androids, right, and you just, like, you know, buzzing in, or you have this one. Yeah. That'd be super awesome. Pretty awesome. I don't know.
不久的将来。不久的将来。不久的将来。不久的将来。理论上。所以最后一篇文章是 NASA 花了 1780 万美元购买一个可充气的国际空间站扩展舱。这就像直接出自科幻小说一样。所以我告诉了一个同事关于这个 Bigelow Space，Bigelow Airspace。
So maybe I get a little too excited about this. No, no, I think this one. Yeah. That'd be super awesome. Pretty awesome. I don't know. So maybe I get a little too excited about this. No, no, I think this is great. I think this is super cool. Can you buy one now or no? No. Oh, not yet. This thing's coming out in the near future.
这是一个拥有连锁酒店的家伙。他有一整家公司，有点像你听说过的 Elon Musk 和 SpaceX，关于把东西送入太空，比如制造太空火箭，这个家伙本质上是一样的，但他想建造太空酒店。所以他有这种凯夫拉和碳纤维之类的概念，无论这些柔性织物是什么，你把它们打包，把它们送到太空中，然后你，你知道，用空气罐之类的给它们充气，它就变成了一个可居住的环境。所以它很小，然后你不需要支付所有这些费用。因为在太空中你没有
The near future. The near future. The near future. The near future. Theoretically. So last article is NASA pays $17.8 million for an inflatable international space station expansion. This is like something straight out of a science fiction book. So I was telling a co-worker about this Bigelow Space, Bigelow Airspace.
和地球上的建筑物一样的要求。重力作用的方式之类的。所以你可以非常不同地设计假设。现在 NASA 显然想要，所以全部细节还没有出来。它们要到明天才会出来。但人们在推测
This is a guy who owned a hotel chain. And he has like a whole company, kind of like you hear about Elon Musk and SpaceX, about getting stuff to space like building space rockets this guy is essentially the same thing but he wants to build space hotels so he has this concept of the like kevlar and carbon fiber whatever these flexible fabrics you pack them down you send them up into space and then you you know inflate them with air tanks or whatever and it becomes a habitable environment. So it's small and then you don't have to pay all this. Because in space you don't have
就像空间站的储藏室。所以我把它送上去，然后连接起来。这很疯狂，对吧？这太棒了。我的意思是，这是一个好主意，对吧？唯一的问题是你怎么把那么多氧气送到那里？我想你必须多跑几趟。好吧，所以我的意思是，所以我——我不是太空工程师。
the same requirements as a building on Earth. The way gravity works and stuff. So you can design the assumptions very differently. Now NASA apparently wants to like, so the full details aren't out yet. They don't come out until tomorrow. But people are speculating
我不是火箭科学家。我不是火箭科学家。我只是在这个播客里扮演一个。但我会想，你可以把它压缩得相当好，所以氧气本身可能重量并不大，明白了，或者空气混合物重量并不大，所以你可以把它压缩到非常高的 PSI，把它储存在，你知道，本质上像液体形式的罐子里，或者什么。好吧，我的意思是，即使只是，你知道，像水肺潜水罐一样，对吧？如果你要膨胀，我不知道水肺潜水罐加压到什么程度，但如果你拿一个
like a storage unit for the space station. So I'll send this up and then attach it. That's crazy, right? That's totally awesome. I mean, it's a great idea, right? The only thing is how do you get that much oxygen up there? I guess you have to make many trips. Well, so I mean, so I would – I'm not a space engineer.
水肺潜水罐，它只是，我很快就会加压，然后你把它膨胀到正常的，你知道，地球大气压，它可能体积大得多。是的，这说得通。所以我们在这里推测我们应该在谈论这些事情之前就知道的事情。好吧，没人知道，还没出来。我们明天得找出答案。所以请继续关注。但那有多酷？我的意思是，所以对你来说，成长过程中太空是一件大事吗？你喜欢火箭并考虑成为宇航员吗？不，我从来没有。我实际上，所以也许我的父母很古怪，
I'm not a rocket scientist. I'm not a rocket scientist. I only play one on this podcast. But I would think like you could compress it fairly well so the oxygen itself probably doesn't weigh that much gotcha or the air mixture doesn't weigh that much so you can compress it to a very high psi store it in you know essentially a tank like a liquid form or something well i mean even just to like you know think like a scuba tank right like if you were to expand i don't know how pressurized the scuba tank is but if you took a
但我们过去常去中世纪集市之类的。所以你想成为一名骑士，而不是宇航员。是的，如果你必须选择的话。真的吗？我实际上两者都不想成为。我觉得两者都相当危险，但是，但是，但是是的，我从来没有迷上太空，但是，但是我能欣赏它。我的意思是，我觉得像这样的东西看起来真的很酷。你带上一个手提箱的事实。
scuba tank that was just i'm soon pretty pressurized and you expanded it to normal you know earth air pressure it probably is much much larger volume yeah that makes sense so here we are speculating about stuff we should probably know this before we talk about these things well nobody knows it's not out yet we'll have to find out tomorrow so so stay tuned but how cool is that like i mean so for you was like space a big thing growing up? Were you into rockets and thinking about being an astronaut? No, I never. I actually, so maybe my parents are wacky,
所以我有一个问题要问你。你会去空间站吗？我绝对会去太空。我会的。就像你会为了去太空做出多少个人牺牲？哦，哇。所以比如，你知道，人们在进行这种对话。我当时想，你会为了去太空做出多少个人牺牲？哦，哇。所以比如，你知道，人们进行这种对话，我当时想，哦，我会去，比如，我觉得去太空真的很酷。我不会，你知道，花他们谈论的那笔钱。我没有那么多钱可以花去太空。但如果它变得足够便宜，比如，你知道，像我现在会去的度假，成本，当然，
but we used to go to medieval fairs and things like that. So you wanted to be a knight, not an astronaut. Yeah, if you had to choose. Really? I didn't actually want to be either. I felt like both were pretty dangerous, but, but, but yeah, I never got into the space thing, but, but I can appreciate it. I mean, I think something like this seems really cool. The fact that you bring up a suitcase.
我会去。是的，其他人说不，我会像现在这样去。当然。我会去。是的。其他人说，不，我不会，比如，风险永远不会低到那种程度。这太危险了。比如他们只是害怕那种恶心感。他们确定他们会忍受。如果你不喜欢它，你要去一个非常、非常不同的环境，对吧？
So I have a question for you. Would you go to space station? I would totally go to space. I would. Like how much, how much personal sacrifice would you do to go to space? Oh, wow. So like, let's say, you know, people were having this conversation. I was like how much how much personal sacrifice would you do to go to space? Oh, wow So like let's say, you know people have this conversation I was like, oh I would go to like I think be really cool to go to space I wouldn't you know spent the amount of money they're talking about I don't have that much money to spend to kind of go up to space But if it became cheap enough like, you know a vacation like I would take now kind of cost to go sure
比如如果你去了那里，你只是，我不是想说得太生动，但你只是整天生病。那会非常痛苦。这不像你可以直接回来。这有点像中西部，我开玩笑的，不，但是，但是我不觉得我意识到有这么高的风险。好吧，我的意思是，对于大多数当前的设计，你坐在一个巨大的爆炸物上面，对吧？所以我的意思是，火箭发动机本质上只是一个受控爆炸，所以你把自己连接到一个巨大的爆炸上。我很好奇，试图得到
I'd go yeah other people are saying no I would like now kind of cost to go. Sure. I'd go. Yeah. Other people were saying, no, I wouldn't like, there's no way the risk will never be low enough. Like it's too dangerous. Like they just are scared of like the nauseousness. They are sure they would endure. If you don't like it, you're going somewhere very, very different environment, right?
百分比，我很好奇飞机坠毁与火箭的百分比，哦，我觉得总是高得多，因为体积太小了，没有那么多，但我只能想到两个火箭，哦，不，更多的火箭，我只能想到两个爆炸的航天飞机。在多少个之中？假设有一个。有五个，对吧？总共有五个，其中两个有灾难性的
Like if you go there and you're just like, I don't mean to be graphic, but you're just sick the whole time. It's gonna be really miserable. It's not like you could just go back. It's like kind of like the midwest i'm just kidding no but but i don't think i didn't realize there was such high risks well i mean you're going for most current designs you're on top of something with a giant explosive right so i mean a rocket engine is basically just a controlled explosion so you're attaching yourself to a giant explosion I wonder though trying to get
故障？不，但那是多少个单元，而不是多少次飞行。好吧，我的意思是，我们可以查一下。这实际上真的很阴森。实际上，它可能仍然比飞机风险大得多。因为你想到有多少架飞机，而且甚至不是每天都有坠机，对吧？
the percent I wonder what the percentage of planes that crash versus rockets oh I think it's far higher for always because the volume is so low there's not that many but I can only think of two rockets oh no more rockets I can only think of two space shuttles that have exploded. Out of how many? Let's say there's one. There was like five, right? There was like five total, and two of them had catastrophic
是的，我的意思是，发生完全死亡的坠机非常罕见。我想这确实风险很大。非常、非常危险。但目前，我的意思是，问题是测量值太低，你没有——好吧，首先，这是一项非常新的技术，所以无论如何都没关系。但随后当前的方法可能与未来的方法非常不同。而且测量率太低，
failures? No, but that's how many units, not how many flights. Okay, I mean, we can look it up. This is kind of actually really grim. Actually, it's probably still much more risky than an airplane. Because you think about how many airplanes there are, and there's not even a crash every day, right?
测量结果会非常嘈杂。是的，这说得通。所以，是的。但是，我的意思是，我认为它总是会有点，它会比乘坐飞机飞行风险更大。我不能，我的意思是，至少在我们的有生之年，对吧？我的意思是，是的，你必须克服的物理力要大得多。而且你可以假设这总是会带来更高的风险，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, it's very rare for there to be a complete fatality kind of crash. I guess it is quite risky. It's very, very risky. But for now, I mean, the problem is the measurement is so low, you don't have – well, first of all, it's a very new technology, so it doesn't matter anyways. But then also the current method may be very different than the future method. And then the measurement rate is so low,
是的，我的意思是，最终，我认为说它不会变得更容易、更常规是天真的。对。我认为如果历史教会了我们什么，那就是我们预期的不会发生的事情。是的，所以我说的任何话都会是错的。我认为它会变得常规，但我认为它也会，比如航空飞行可能会变得安全得多。所以也许未来前往充气太空酒店的航天飞机飞行会像当前的飞机飞行一样危险。哦，我明白了。
the measurement would be very noisy. Yeah, that makes sense. So, yeah. But, I mean, I think it's always going to be somewhat, it's going to be more risky than taking a plane flight. I can't, I mean, at least for probably our lifetimes, right? I mean, yeah, just the physical forces you have to overcome are much greater. And you could assume that that always is going to incur higher risk, right?
这说得通。我不知道。是的，我们走着瞧。我现在在编这些东西。看，如果我们在这方面做得很好，我们就可以，比如，回到这个播客，然后，比如，成为未来学家。哦，看看我们的预测。因为我们可以，比如，看，我们预测了这会发生。我们应该做出更大胆的声明，Jason。
Yeah, I mean, eventually, I would think it would be naive to say it won't become easier routine. Right. I think if history teaches us something, it's that whatever we expect to not happen. Yeah, so whatever I say will be wrong. I think it will become routine, but I think it will also, like air flight will probably become much safer. So maybe future shuttle flights to the inflatable space hotel will be as risky as current airplane flights are. Oh, I see.
是的，完全正确。我认为它明天就会发生。哇。现在，实际上，好问题。好吧，你认为五年内人类会商业化进入太空吗？我说五年。我说两年。你说两年？
That makes sense. I don't know. Yeah, we'll see. I'm making this stuff up now. See, if we did really good at this, we could, like, go back to this podcast and then, like, become futurists. Oh, see our predictions. Because we could, like, look, we predicted this was going to happen. We should be making bolder claims, Jason.
我们只说少于五年。如果少于五年，你就赢了。所以你必须说多少，我不知道，好吧。但这非常模糊。它必须非常具体，对吧？五年内人类在太空中的人天数是多少？多少人天？所以人数乘以总天数。我这样告诉你。我认为 1% 的人口会在一年内去太空度假。而且我认为那将是五年。哦，真的吗？那太激进了。哦，好吧。我只是以为你的意思是你可以商业化，比如现在如果你想买票进入太空，它确实存在，但我的意思是它不是
Yeah, totally. I think it'll happen tomorrow. Wow. Now, actually, good question. Okay, do you think there will be humans in space, like, commercially in five years? I say five years. I say two. You say two years?
真正的商业化。它是定制的。你知道，你必须乘坐联盟号火箭。你不认为这需要五年才能……我当时说两年，两年，基本上让非常有钱的人能够买到去太空的票。哦，好吧，你认为这需要更长的时间。我想是的，我会说它可能，是的，就像超过 50% 的人口有权访问，或者在你的情况下，1% 的人类将进行太空休闲旅行。你认为那个数字超过五年吗？
Let's just say less than five. If it's less than five, you win. So you've got to say how many, I don't know, okay. But it's very vague. It's got to be very specific, right? How many man days will humans be in space in five years? Okay. Will it be greater or less than 10,000? How many man days? So number of men or women times the number of total days. I'll put it to you this way. I think 1% of the population will have gone into space for a
我们就说少于五个吧。如果少于五个，你就赢了。所以你得说出具体是多少，我不知道，好吧。但这太模糊了。必须非常具体，对吧？五年内人类在太空中的人天数是多少？好吧。会大于还是小于一万？多少人天？也就是人数乘以总天数。我这样跟你说吧，我认为百分之一的人口会在一年内去太空度假。
vacation in a year. And I think that that is going to be five years. Oh, really? That's really aggressive. Oh, okay. I was just thinking you meant like you could commercially, like right now if you wanted to buy your way into space, it kind of exists, but I mean it's not
而且我认为那会是在五年内。哦，真的吗？那太激进了。哦，好吧。我刚才以为你的意思是像现在这样，如果你想花钱去太空，这种方式其实已经存在了，但我的意思是它并不是
really commercial. It's custom. You know, you've got to go on the Soyuz rocket. You don't think it would take five years to I was saying two years two years basically for very rich people to be able to buy a ticket to space oh well you're thinking it's gonna take much longer I think yeah I would say it's probably gonna yeah it's like the greater than 50% of the population has access to or your to your case 1% of humans will have recreationally traveled to space. You think that number is more than five years?
真正的商业化。它是定制的。你知道，你得乘坐联盟号火箭。你不觉得这需要五年吗？我说的是两年，基本上两年内非常有钱的人就能买到去太空的票。哦，那你觉得这需要更长的时间。我想是的，我会说这大概会……是的，就像超过百分之五十的人口能够接触到，或者按你的说法，百分之一的人类会进行太空休闲旅行。你觉得这个数字需要超过五年吗？
Yeah, I think that's more than five years. All right. Well, because also, I mean, there's a lot of people on the world who don't have a car, don't have access to clean running water, right? So, like, you've got to already, those people in five years, I mean, they're going to go from that to recreational space flight? Yeah. This episode is really, like, I mean,
是啊，我觉得那不止五年。好吧。因为，我的意思是，世界上有很多人没有车，没有干净的自来水，对吧？所以，五年内这些人要从那种生活跨越到太空旅游？是啊。这一集真的，我的意思是，
I feel really bad now. I guess I didn't think about all of the people in the world. I was only thinking about like, the subset of people who were candidates, like, who would want to go into space, you know? You don't think those people want to go to space? I'm sure they do want to go to space. You don't think they look up at the stars and wish, like, oh, I wish I could
我现在感觉很糟糕。我想我没考虑到世界上所有的人。我只考虑了那些候选人，就是那些想去太空的人，你知道吗？你不觉得那些人也想去太空吗？我相信他们肯定想去太空。你不觉得他们抬头仰望星空时会许愿，比如，哦，我希望我能
go there? Well, this wish I could go there. Well, this is really off topic now. Anyways, we'll talk. We'll have to come back to that. Okay. Let us know if you find this interesting or tell us to shut up and keep to our claimed expertise.
去那里吗？好吧，这个“我希望我能去那里”。好吧，这现在完全跑题了。总之，我们以后再聊。我们得回到这个话题。好的。如果你觉得这很有趣，请告诉我们，或者让我们闭嘴，只谈我们声称擅长的领域。
Yeah. So anyway, speaking of our claimed expertise, it is the tool of the show. So my tool of the show is something that I think is pretty freaking cool. It's a Ripple emulator. It's actually not a Ripple emulator, but it's called Ripple emulator. And what it is, it's pretty cool. It's an extension for Chrome.
是啊。总之，说到我们声称擅长的领域，这就是本节目的工具环节。我带来的工具是我认为非常酷的东西。它叫 Ripple 模拟器。其实它不是 Ripple 模拟器，但名字就叫 Ripple 模拟器。它非常酷，是一个 Chrome 扩展程序。
And you attach it, and it puts a button in the top right of your Chrome browser. And then you click the button, and you can actually simulate what the site looks like under different phones. Oh. Yeah, so you can click it and say BlackBerry, and it'll show you what your site looks like. I thought I was going to be able to drop a stone in a pond and watch the ripples. The whole website would just ripple outwards. Yes, okay. But it's pretty cool.
你安装它之后，Chrome 浏览器的右上角会出现一个按钮。点击那个按钮，你就可以模拟网站在不同手机上的显示效果。哦。是啊，你可以点击它，选择 BlackBerry，它就会显示你的网站在黑莓手机上的样子。我还以为我能往池塘里扔块石头，看着涟漪扩散呢。整个网站都会像涟漪一样向外扩散。是的，好吧。但它真的很酷。
This seems more useful. Yeah, yeah. It actually uses the emulators of the devices and things like that. How fast is it? Is it pretty fast? It's pretty fast. It's, you know, I haven't tried it on dynamic content. I've only tried it on, you know, static webpages.
这看起来更有用。是啊，是啊。它实际上使用了设备的模拟器之类的东西。它快吗？速度挺快吗？挺快的。你知道，我还没在动态内容上试过。我只在静态网页上试过。
But it feels very responsive. Have you tested for accuracy? Like, take a device you own and, like, compare? No, I haven't done that either. Sorry, I didn't mean to deflate your balloon dude no but so i haven't done like rigorous testing of this but i have used it to sort of verify like a site i was working on that how it looked in android oh okay and uh you know i haven't checked pixel by pixel but no no no i didn't mean that i just mean like yeah did it generally give you a better feel? Oh, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Better than just resizing your window down to the right pixels.
但它感觉响应非常快。你测试过准确性吗？比如，拿一个你拥有的设备对比一下？不，我还没做过那个。抱歉，我不是故意要打击你的积极性，伙计。不，我没做过严格的测试，但我用它验证过我正在开发的一个网站在 Android 上的显示效果。哦，好的。呃，你知道，我没逐像素检查过，但……不，不，我不是那个意思，我只是说，它总体上给了你更好的感觉吗？哦，是的。好的。是啊。比单纯把窗口缩放到合适的像素尺寸要好。
Yeah, yeah. Resolution. No, it definitely did better than that. Okay. Well, good tool then, sir. And so it covers, like, different browsers on different, you know, platforms and things like that. And it'll actually warn you if you have something that's, let's say,
是啊，是啊。分辨率。不，它绝对比那个好。好的。那是个好工具，先生。它涵盖了不同平台上的不同浏览器之类的东西。如果你有某些东西，比如说，
like, Mac-specific or desktop-specific that, like, a phone won't know how to handle or things like that. So yeah, it's actually made by, or it's made by a company that was bought by BlackBerry, so by RIM. So they should, it should be pretty well maintained and things like that.
是 Mac 专用或桌面专用的，手机不知道怎么处理，它实际上会警告你。所以，是的，它是由一家被黑莓（RIM）收购的公司制作的。所以它应该维护得相当好。
So if you do any mobile development or you want to see how your website works on an Android or a BlackBerry or some other, check out this Ripple emulator extension. I feel like I should make a joke about, like, RIM stock price or something at this point. I don't want to offend anybody. It's not a simulator. It can't do it all. I feel like, oh, no, never mind.
所以如果你做移动开发，或者想看看你的网站在 Android、黑莓或其他设备上如何运行，去看看这个 Ripple 模拟器扩展吧。我觉得我这时候应该开个关于 RIM 股价的玩笑什么的。我不想冒犯任何人。它不是模拟器。它不能做所有事。我觉得，哦，不，算了。
Poor RIM. I'll just. Remember when RIM went down and there were riots in London? Yeah, so RIM, like... Aren't they in Canada? They're in Canada, but something happened to their London thing, and there were actually riots. Or, no, actually, the riots...
可怜的 RIM。我只是……还记得 RIM 倒闭时伦敦发生的骚乱吗？是啊，所以 RIM，就像……他们不是在加拿大吗？他们在加拿大，但他们的伦敦分部出了点事，确实发生了骚乱。或者，不，其实，骚乱……
We are totally, like, making... We don't have, like, a story about this or anything. Hang on. We're going to totally mess this up, dude. So, okay. Something about RIM riots. Okay. The UK riots, R riots rim and the race
我们完全是在……我们没有关于这个的故事什么的。等等。伙计，我们要把这事搞砸了。所以，好吧。关于 RIM 骚乱的事。好吧。英国骚乱，R 骚乱，RIM 和种族……
price of price anyways so yeah ripple emulator check it out bought by room so what is your totally they didn't pay in in rim stock yeah this show is sponsored by rim sponsored by rims competitors oh sorry mine is the very, very, very useful tool. I could not get by without this. Really? If you don't have this, I don't even know how you get any work done. Really?
价格，价格，总之，是的，Ripple 模拟器，去看看吧，被 RIM 收购了，所以你们完全……他们没用 RIM 的股票支付。是啊，本节目由 RIM 赞助，由 RIM 的竞争对手赞助。哦，抱歉，我的是一个非常、非常、非常有用的工具。没有它我简直没法工作。真的吗？如果你没有这个，我甚至不知道你是怎么完成工作的。真的吗？
That is the game Battle of the Bulge for the iPad. This looks awesome. So this is a war game for your iPad. It does not work on iPhone. It does not work on Android. It does not work on Android. Nothing. I'm a horrible, horrible person. Supposedly I guess one is in the works.
那就是 iPad 上的《突出部之役》（Battle of the Bulge）游戏。这看起来太棒了。所以这是一个 iPad 战争游戏。它不能在 iPhone 上运行。它不能在 Android 上运行。它不能在 Android 上运行。什么都没有。我真是个糟糕透顶的人。据说好像有一个正在开发中。
But yeah, so this is a really, really, really awesome game. It strikes an awesome balance between a true war game, if you ever play a real war game with all the little cards and allies. No cards no no no like oh i don't like the what is the name of that company that does all them oh i can't think of the
但是的，这是一个非常、非常、非常棒的游戏。它在真正的战争游戏和那种你玩过的带有小卡片和盟友的游戏之间取得了极好的平衡。没有卡片，不，不，不，就像……哦，我不喜欢那家制作所有这些游戏的公司叫什么名字，哦，我想不起来……
avalon hill with all the little cardboard squares and the hex maps and like a book that's like 50 pages thick like okay if you ever play one i never actually managed to play one of those but i've seen them people playing them yeah and then like risk or access analysis kind of simple this kind of like strikes a balance in between. So the nice thing is the computer handles a lot of the accounting bookkeeping for you. They threw a lot of like really thematic elements into it. But yeah, it's like you can sit down
Avalon Hill，带有所有那些小纸板方块和六角地图，还有一本 50 页厚的书，就像……好吧，如果你玩过一个，我从来没真正玩过那些，但我见过人们玩。是啊，还有像《风险》（Risk）或《轴心国与同盟国》（Axis & Allies）那种简单的，这个介于两者之间。所以好的一点是，电脑为你处理了很多计算和记账工作。他们加入了很多非常主题化的元素。但是的，就像你可以坐下来，
and lose really easily. Like, you know, it's really fun to just drag the guys around and then completely you lose because the game is really hard and I've never won, not even once. Oh man. I got a tie once.
然后很容易就输了。就像，你知道，拖动那些小人然后彻底输掉真的很有趣，因为游戏真的很难，我一次都没赢过，一次都没有。天哪。我有一次平局。
But it's actually really fun. And I've kind of always wanted to, like, imagine myself as being, like, an awesome strategy war game person. But I kind of find I'm pretty terrible at, like, strategy. Even, like, you ever play, like, the turn-based games, like Final Fantasy Tactics or, like, any of these styles? Yeah, yeah, or Advance Wars. Yeah, or Advance Wars. I'm terrible
但它真的很有趣。我一直想把自己想象成一个很棒的战略战争游戏玩家。但我发现我在战略方面真的很糟糕。甚至，你玩过那种回合制游戏吗，比如《最终幻想战略版》或者任何这类风格的？是啊，是啊，或者《高级战争》（Advance Wars）。是啊，或者《高级战争》。我玩所有这些游戏都
at all of those games. I really envision myself as this awesome game guy and really good strategy. I'm just terrible. In my old age, I've kind of That sounds really bad. But I'm just kind of embracing the fact that I played this game
很烂。我真的把自己设想成一个很棒的游戏玩家，战略很好。我只是很烂。在我这个年纪，我已经……这听起来很糟糕。但我只是接受了我玩这个游戏
on the easy setting. I don't even i don't even fathom like how i would ever beat it one thing i've noticed is that some of these games demand a lot of micromanagement and so like what if if you're like not specifically moving like each person then like you can get burned just no no so this one i mean this one uh so it's not like the individual it's what they call like a. So you're managing kind of like a squad. And it's similar to kind of Advance Wars. It's about the same level.
是在简单模式下。我甚至无法想象我怎么能赢。我注意到的一件事是，其中一些游戏需要大量的微观管理，所以如果你不是专门移动每个人，那么你可能会被烧毁。不，不，所以这个，我的意思是这个……所以它不像个人，它是他们所说的……所以你管理的是一个小队。它类似于《高级战争》。水平差不多。
We probably, people don't even know what we're talking about. That's okay. So, you know, you're kind of moving the people around. And then there's like very complicated like conditions. And I think that's what I'm not accounting for. Like, oh, this is like an elite squad. But he's attacking somebody like in a forest. So, like, he's got a defensive bonus for being in a forest and I haven't
我们可能……人们甚至不知道我们在说什么。没关系。所以，你知道，你是在移动那些人。然后还有非常复杂的条件。我想这就是我没有考虑到的。比如，哦，这是一个精英小队。但他正在攻击森林里的人，所以，他因为在森林里而有防御加成，而我还没有……
I've only played like five or six times but I haven't yet gotten to that like oh I need to be I need to move my guy to the right to be on top of the hill so I can attack down onto the people as opposed to just attacking them straight and just like watching my people die so it's kind of interesting if you have an iPad. I want me never to go to war
我只玩了五六次，但我还没达到那种“哦，我需要把我的家伙向右移动到山顶上，这样我就可以向下攻击那些人，而不是直接攻击他们，看着我的人死去”的程度。所以如果你有 iPad，这很有趣。我永远不想和你一起去打仗，
with you as the commander. Yes you should not let me direct your war. I would not do well, according to my previous experiences. We'll just train everybody to be hackers, and we'll just do it from the safety of our desks. Yeah, exactly. So people should check this out if they have an iPad, which greatly I know narrows down.
你是指挥官。是的，你不应该让我指挥你的战争。根据我之前的经验，我不会做得很好。我们还是把大家都训练成黑客吧，我们就在办公桌的安全地带操作。是啊，完全正确。所以如果人们有 iPad，应该去看看这个，我知道这大大缩小了范围。
It doesn't work on iPhone or iPod Touches. Well, we'll have to say as soon as it does. But it is a little expensive at $10, but I found it like one of the games that's like really, really well made. Not just like, oh, we reported this over or whatever, but like this one's really well made and I really enjoyed it over the Christmas break. Yeah, that sounds awesome, man. So is it easier to hack somebody if they're on a mountain,
它不能在 iPhone 或 iPod Touch 上运行。好吧，我们一有消息就说。但它有点贵，要 10 美元，但我发现它是那种制作得非常、非常好的游戏之一。不仅仅是，哦，我们移植了这个之类的，而是这个真的制作得很好，我在圣诞假期期间玩得很开心。是啊，那听起来太棒了，伙计。那么如果他们在山上，黑掉某人会更容易，
or do you pay a penalty for that? It depends on what mountain. Oh, that's true. Maybe it's Iron Mountain. Because if it's like NORAD, that's probably pretty hard to hack. Also, if the mountain is very tall, connectivity might be bad, so it might be hard to hack them because you probably don't have a reliable connection to them. You just reminded me of something.
还是你会因此受到惩罚？这取决于是什么山。哦，那倒是。也许是“铁山”（Iron Mountain）。因为如果是像北美防空司令部（NORAD）那样，那可能很难黑。另外，如果山很高，连接性可能很差，所以可能很难黑他们，因为你可能没有与他们的可靠连接。你刚才提醒了我一件事。
Speaking of connections. That was a joke for everybody playing along at home. DAVID EASTMANN PENNAHILLIER- Somebody at work who's a hardware engineer happens to sit next to me. My phone kept going off. And I would leave my phone when I would go to a restroom or a meeting or something.
说到连接。那是给家里所有跟着玩的人开的一个玩笑。DAVID EASTMANN PENNAHILLIER——公司里有个硬件工程师正好坐在我旁边。我的手机一直响。我离开手机去洗手间或开会时，
And my phone would go off. And he was getting annoyed with it. He finally took those static, the things that, like if you buy a GPU or you buy a hard drive, it comes in a static bag. Conductive bag. He took, like, four of those, and he put one inside the other, and then he put my phone in that. And it's basically a Faraday cage. I didn't realize that.
我的手机就会响。他对此感到很烦。他最后拿了那些防静电的东西，就是如果你买 GPU 或硬盘，它会装在防静电袋里。导电袋。他拿了四个，一个套一个，然后把我的手机放进去。这基本上就是一个法拉第笼。我没意识到这一点。
He had grounded it, yeah, but pretty close. Yeah, I mean, and then he, like, just closed the lid. He didn't tape it shut or anything. And my phone totally had no connectivity. Did he tell you he did no he just waited for you to come back he just waited for me to come back and i was like look at your phone i found it wrapped in static bags but i didn't think that that would work but it does wow yeah i think it i think it does i mean it really attenuates the signal very strongly
他把它接地了，是啊，但非常接近。是啊，我的意思是，然后他就像，只是盖上了盖子。他没有用胶带封死什么的。我的手机完全没有连接信号。他告诉你他做了吗？没有，他只是等你回来。他只是等我回来，我就像，看看你的手机，我发现它被包在防静电袋里，但我没想到那会起作用，但它确实起作用了。哇，是啊，我想它……我想它确实起作用，我的意思是它非常强烈地衰减了信号。
yeah yeah i didn't i don't guess i don't know so i used to think faraday cage too but then somebody told me i said that one time basically like you said and then i got a you got an ear verbal lashing yeah someone actually knows yeah because the faraday cage needs to be grounded so if you think about it essentially the radio waves are coming in so if you had strong enough uh signal it would uh charge the bag i'm butchering this because i know nothing about more than me but like the essentially the bag would start becoming an antenna because you're able to manipulate the charge on the bag. Versus if it's grounded, every time the charge builds up, it just would go straight into the ground.
是啊，是啊，我没……我猜我不知道。所以我以前也认为是法拉第笼，但后来有人告诉我，我曾经有一次像你那样说，然后我被……你被骂了一顿。是啊，有人真的懂。因为法拉第笼需要接地。所以如果你想一想，本质上无线电波进来了，所以如果你有足够强的信号，它会给袋子充电。我把这搞砸了，因为我对此一无所知，但本质上袋子会开始变成天线，因为你能够操纵袋子上的电荷。而如果它接地了，每次电荷积累，它就会直接进入地面。
That's my, like, I probably butchered it. We're going to have people email us and tell us. No, no, no. I think that makes a lot of sense. I mean, you probably know more electrical engineering than, like, 99.99% of the population. No. So, anyway.
这就是我的……我可能搞砸了。我们会有人们给我们发邮件告诉我们。不，不，不。我觉得这很有道理。我的意思是，你可能比 99.99% 的人口更懂电气工程。不。所以，总之。
Thank you for that compliment. It's true. Maybe. Think about population. No. So anyway. Thank you for that compliment. It's true. Maybe. Think about it. Okay, so again. Time for book of the show. Book of the show. Our newest,
谢谢你的夸奖。这是真的。也许吧。想想人口。不。所以，总之。谢谢你的夸奖。这是真的。也许吧。想想看。好的，那么再次。到了本节目的图书环节。图书环节。我们最新的，
oh no, I guess newest segment was question of the show. Well. Book of the show. Book of the show is pretty awesome. So my book of the show is, I have it right here. This sound is...
哦不，我想最新的环节是本节目的问题。好吧。图书环节。图书环节非常棒。所以我的图书是，我正好在这里。这个声音是……
Here, maybe drop it on the table. No, no, don't do that. It's pretty heavy. It's a hard cover. This is Reinforcement Learning and Introduction. So trees were killed to make that book for you. That's true. That's kind of sad.
给，也许把它扔在桌子上。不，不，别那样做。它很重。它是精装本。这是《强化学习：导论》（Reinforcement Learning: An Introduction）。所以为了给你做那本书，树木被砍伐了。那是真的。那有点悲伤。
I'm sorry. I don't know. I'm sorry, guys. I haven't even finished it yet. So some of the trees died in vain. Yeah, so she's at one in the beginning. Why are we... Anyways.
我很抱歉。我不知道。我很抱歉，伙计们。我还没读完呢。所以有些树白死了。是啊，所以她在开头……为什么我们……总之。
We need to be more upbeat reinforcement learning an introduction by uh richard sutton and andrew bartow um so a little bit about reinforcement learning you know we were thinking maybe doing like a whole machine learning podcast but um just a quick synopsis of reinforcement learning what makes it different um you know so traditional machine learning you do the the, oh, for example, like if, you know, so one thing they do is they measure, like, babies, right? They measure the distance from, like, I think the baby's hip to their knee. Okay, so we switch from artificial, so real life, real doctors.
我们需要更乐观一点。《强化学习：导论》，作者是理查德·萨顿（Richard Sutton）和安德鲁·巴托（Andrew Barto）。嗯，关于强化学习的一点知识，你知道我们曾想过做一个关于机器学习的播客，但……只是对强化学习做一个快速总结，是什么让它与众不同……你知道，所以传统的机器学习，你做……哦，例如，如果你……所以他们做的一件事是，他们测量，比如，婴儿，对吧？他们测量婴儿从，我想是臀部到膝盖的距离。好的，所以我们从人工智能切换到现实生活，真正的医生。
Oh, yeah, so real doctors. Okay, okay. And they measure, like, from the baby's hip to their knee. I shouldn't say real doctors. That's not a bad, medical doctors. And that distance they use to figure out how tall the person is going to be when they're an adult. Okay.
哦，是啊，所以真正的医生。好的，好的。他们测量，比如，从婴儿的臀部到膝盖。我不应该说真正的医生。那不是坏的，医学博士。他们用那个距离来计算这个人成年后会有多高。好的。
And obviously it's not like one-to-one. There's some function that maps that. And so you could actually take a bunch of babies, measure them at their babyhood, measure them again when they're adults. We should say doctors should take a bunch of babies. Don't try this at home. And then you can come up with some function using regression or something like that, like simple
显然它不是一对一的。有一个函数映射它。所以你实际上可以找一群婴儿，在他们婴儿时期测量他们，在他们成年后再测量一次。我们应该说医生应该找一群婴儿。别在家里尝试这个。然后你可以使用回归或类似的技术得出一个函数，比如简单的
machine learning techniques to figure out so that when you get baby number x plus one, then you know how tall they're going to be. So that's regular machine learning. Reinforcement learning is when you have to make a lot of decisions. So by contrast, let's say you want to have a machine
机器学习技术来计算，这样当你得到第 x+1 个婴儿时，你就知道他们会长多高。所以那是常规的机器学习。强化学习是当你必须做出很多决定时。所以相比之下，假设你想让一台机器
like play checkers so you make the very first move but the problem is you haven't learned anything right the very first move doesn't tell you like was this a good move is a bad move right so you only get a reinforcement you only get like you only get a value at the end like when you've lost the game or won the game okay and somehow you have to take that like oh i oh, I lost the checkers game. I'm really disappointed. And you have to think about all the things you did and which ones of those caused you to lose, or which things the
玩跳棋，所以你迈出了第一步，但问题是你什么都没学到，对吧？第一步并没有告诉你，比如，这是一个好棋还是坏棋，对吧？所以你只得到一个强化，你只得到……你只在最后得到一个值，比如当你输掉游戏或赢得游戏时。好的，你必须以某种方式接受那个……哦，我输了跳棋游戏。我真的很失望。你必须思考你所做的所有事情，其中哪些导致你输了，或者对手做了哪些对他来说很棒的事情导致你输了，反之亦然，如果你赢了。强化学习让你做那一部分。我觉得我需要安静地坐在这里。好的。所以它不像，哦，我有所有这些数据，所有这些 X、Y 点，我只需要拟合一个函数到这些点。它更像是，我有所有这些数据，只有其中一些我知道是好是坏。
opponent did which were great for him which caused you to lose, and vice versa if you win. Reinforcement learning lets you do that piece of it. I think I need to sit here quietly. Okay. So it's not like, oh, I have all this data, all these like X, Y points, and I just like need to fit like a function to these points. It's more like I have all this data and only some of it I know was good or bad.
所以换句话说，比如你在所有游戏中下的最后几步棋，导致你输掉游戏的棋，比如，你知道那步棋很坏，或者那步棋是糟糕游戏的一部分。但你不一定知道导致它的所有棋都是坏的。其中一些可能很棒，
So in other words, like all the last moves you played in all the games, which caused like the move, which lost you the game, like, you know that that move was bad or that move was part of a bad game. But you don't necessarily know all the moves that led up to it were bad. Some of them might have been great,
但后来你因为其他原因输了，对吧？比如，其中两步棋可能很棒，但接下来的 28 步很坏，对吧？所以强化学习让你处理问题的那个部分。如果你想要一个入门，你可以读这本书。我觉得我需要一个入门。是的，我应该读这本书。
but then you lost because of other reasons, right? Like, two of the moves might have been great, but then the next 28 were bad, right? So reinforcement learning lets you do that part of the problem. And if you want an introduction to that, you can read this book. I feel like I need an introduction to that. Yes, I should read this book.
另一个更简单的例子是如果有人在你的网站上。人们在你的网站上。他们花了很多时间。他们访问了很多链接。他们玩得很开心。然后你做了一些改变。假设你做了 200 个改变或一堆链接，他们玩得很开心，然后你做了一些改变，假设你做了 200 个改变或一堆改变，然后人们他们开始离开你的网站，或者他们开始不在你的网站上花足够的时间，或者也许，你知道，每个访问你网站上 A、C 和 D 站点的人，按那个顺序，他们
Another simpler example would be if someone's on your website. And people are on your website. They're spending a lot of time. They're visiting a lot of links. And they're having a good time. And then you make some changes. Let's say you make like 200 changes or a bunch of links and they're having good time and then you make some changes let's say you make like like 200 changes or a bunch of changes and then people they start just dropping off your website or they start not spending enough time on your website or maybe you know everyone who goes to this like you're everyone who visits sites a c and d on your website like in that order they
再也不会访问你的网站了，所以强化学习实际上会给你那些答案，所以你可以把每个人的访问历史记录放入强化学习算法中，它实际上会拆解出哪些站点和哪些行为是好是坏。这听起来很酷。是啊，就像我应该读这本书。这能让你做一些非常棒的事情吗？不过我觉得我可能理解不了。不，这是一个导论。导论怎么样？
never visit your site again so reinforcement learning will actually give you uh those answers so you could just put in everybody's sort of like their visit history through your website into a reinforcement learning algorithm and it'll actually tease apart like what you know sites and what actions are good and bad that sounds pretty cool yeah it's like i should read this book does this let you do some really awesome stuff? I feel like I probably won't understand it, though. No, this is an introduction. How's the introduction?
好的，但我以前被告知过。帕特里克一直在继续。不，所以我实际上……这是我读的第一本书。所以如果有人，所以拿我举个例子。非常、非常少，你知道，人工智能。我能读吗，比如，它包含……我需要知道，比如人工智能吗？不，你完全可以……所以这是我的第一本人工智能书。是啊，这会很好。我的意思是，你可能需要知道
Okay, so, but I've been told that before. Patrick's kept going. No, so I actually, this is one of the first books I read. So if somebody, so take me for an example. Very, very little, you know, artificial intelligence. Could I read the, like, does it contain, do I need to know, like artificial intelligence no you can totally so this is my first artificial intelligence book yeah this would be good i mean you might need to know
机器学习的基础知识，比如读一下《机器学习导论》之类的可能会有帮助。好的，但即使你没读过，这本书，它有很多非常简单的例子，比如它从某种程度上开始，比如，你知道，开车和你的通勤时间，试图估计你的通勤时间。所以这是一个非常具体的例子，他们把这个例子贯穿整本书，而且……我认为它开始时你不需要很多知识。所以它是用领域语言写的还是普通语言写的？换句话说，即使我没有完全理解所有概念，我还能读它并从中学习东西吗？哦，是的。
the very basics of machine learning like it might help to read machine learning an introduction or something like that okay but even if you didn't this book it has a bunch of really simple examples like it starts with kind of like you know driving and like your commute time trying to estimate your commute time to work so it's a very concrete example and they kind of carry this example through the whole book and uh i think it starts off with with you don't need a lot of knowledge so is it written in domain language or normal language like in other words can i read it even if i don't fully get all the concepts while i still learn stuff out of it? Oh, yeah.
完全可以。我的意思是，它里面有一些方程，但数学并不太重。好的。它不试图通过方程来教我。对。好的。像那样的书，我读起来有困难。我只是……
Totally. I mean, it has a few equations in it, but it's not too math heavy. Okay. It doesn't try to teach me through the equations. Right. Okay. Books like that, I have trouble reading books like that. I just don't.
我需要，比如，用简单的词告诉我概念。它用文字作为图片。而且前几章可以在线免费阅读。所以你可以从那里开始。导论的导论。是啊，完全正确。这本书有导论吗？
I need to, like, have the concept told to me in plain words. It does words as pictures. And they have the first couple of chapters are available online for free. So you can start with that. An introduction to the introduction. Yeah, exactly. Does this book have an introduction?
我不知道。好吧，前几章……哦，第一章是导论。它确实有导论的导论。那么，你的本周图书是什么？因为我学得慢，我要选另一本小说。这本是《头号玩家》（Ready Player One），
I don't know. Well, the first few chapters... Oh, first chapter is an introduction. It does have an introduction to the introduction. And with that, what is your book of the show? Since I'm a slow learner, I'm going to go with another fiction book. This one is Ready Player One
作者是恩斯特·克莱恩（Ernest Cline）。这本书实际上非常、非常受欢迎。我想它甚至在《纽约时报》畅销书榜上待了一段时间。此时此刻它已经有一年半的历史了。但这本书读起来真的、真的很有趣。
by Ernest Cline. This book was actually really, really popular. I think it even made the New York Times bestseller list for a while. It's about a year and a half old at this point. But this book is really, really a fun read.
我读这本书很开心。这看起来很酷。它非常令人愉快。这本书的作者基本上把他对 80 年代的热爱的一切，都放进了一本设定在未来的书里。啊。所以我有点错过了那条船。就像，你知道，这不是秘密。
I had a good time reading this. This looks cool. It's very enjoyable. And the author of this basically took everything that he loved about the 80s and, like, put it into a book that was set in the future. Ah. And so I kind of missed that boat a little. Like, you know, there's no secret.
就像，我没那么老。所以，我了解大部分参考资料，但它们更像是……我不太清楚它们到底是什么。而且肯定有很多参考资料我错过了。但，你知道，我还是理解了很多。比如，你知道，有关于《吃豆人》（Pac-Man）的参考资料。不仅仅是参考资料，甚至只是谈论《吃豆人》。还有很多人试图理解关于《龙与地下城》以及这类事情的文化。这真的是一个好故事。
Like, I'm not that old. So, like, I knew most of the references, but they were more like I kind of didn't know exactly what they were. And there were a lot of references I'm sure I missed. But, you know, I still did get a bunch of it. Like, you know, there's references to Pac-Man. And not just, like, references, but even just talking about Pac-Man. And a lot of people trying to understand the culture about, about like Dungeons and Dragons and about these kinds of things. It's really a good story.
我真的很喜欢它。它不像你读的一些科幻小说，比如，天哪，这真的很深刻。它让我思考未来，比如，你知道，关于这些东西。它只是读起来很有趣。你知道，你读一本书，它读起来很容易，而且很有趣。这就是这本书。一旦你开始读，就像，哦，再读一章。我只想找到它。
I really enjoyed it. It wasn't like some science fiction you read where it's like, oh, man, this is like really deep. It made me think about like the future and like, you know, about this stuff. It was just like a fun read. You know, you read a book and it's like really easy to read and really fun. This was this book. And once you start reading, it's like, oh, just one more chapter. I just want to find it.
再读一章。再读一章。是啊，我一直在找像这样的书。就像我想要一些更轻松的东西。我觉得就是它了。所以我觉得，加上所有的文化参考，它几乎就像一个持续的笑话，你知道，就像所有这些关于各种电影和游戏的流行文化，
Just one more chapter. Just one more chapter. Yeah, I've been looking for a book like this. Like I kind of want something more light. I feel like this is it. So I feel like, and plus with all the cultural references, it's kind of like just like a running joke almost, you know, like just like all this pop culture to various movies and games and,
你知道，80 年代的昙花一现的明星，所有这些东西。所以如果你还没读过，我绝对推荐这本书。所以我不知道，我也和 80 年代脱节了。我还能理解足够多吗？是啊，所以，我的意思是，
you know, one hit wonders from the 80s, all those kinds of things. So I would definitely recommend this if you haven't read it yet. So I don't, I'm kind of out of touch also with the 80s. Like, would I still get enough of it? Yeah, so, I mean,
我认为没有那个它也是一本好书。好的。所以，因为你会……我的意思是，你会知道东西，对吧？因为很多 80 年代的东西今天仍然存在。比如，我的意思是，你知道什么是《吃豆人》，对吧？是啊，是啊。
I think it's a good book without that. Okay. So, because you'll, I mean, you'll know stuff, right? Because a lot of this stuff from the 80s still exists today. Like, I mean, you know what Pac-Man is, right? Yeah, yeah.
你知道，而且你知道很多这些东西会是什么。我想《回到未来》里也有一些东西。那是真的吗？我不记得了。显然里面有德罗宁跑车。总之，所以
You know, and you know what a lot of these things will be. Back to the Future kind of has some stuff in there, I guess. Is that true? I don't remember. DeLorean is in it, apparently. Anyway, so
你会知道里面的东西，即使不知道，它读起来仍然很有趣。我去参加了一个作者实际上在签名售书之类的演讲。我就想，哦，好的，这会很好。我真的很喜欢这本书什么的。所以我去听他讲。他说他采取的方法很有趣。
you'll know stuff in there, and even if not, it's still a fun read. I went to a presentation the author actually did where he was signing books and stuff. And I was like, oh, okay, this will be good. I really like this book or whatever. So I went to hear him talk. And he was saying how the approach he took to doing this was kind of interesting.
但他告诉我们，有一些青少年显然在 80 年代还没出生。他们读了它，他们读了电子书版本，并且打开维基百科，每次有他们不懂的参考资料，他们就在维基百科上查。不错。所以到最后他们有点……这实际上非常迷人，因为它类似于发生的事情，在不剧透太多的情况下，它发生在书中的人身上。所以书中的人是关于未来的孩子试图了解 80 年代的文化。哦，我明白了。所以一个有趣的副作用是，这真的发生在现实中。是的，所以现在的人们实际上是在学习 80 年代的文化来理解这本书。是啊，总之去看看吧，它非常元，我喜欢它。
But he told that there were, like, teenagers who obviously weren't even alive in the 80s. And they read it and they read the book the ebook version and have wikipedia open and every time there's a reference they don't get they look it up in wikipedia nice and so by the end they kind of and this is actually really fascinating because it's similar to what happens without giving away a lot it happens to people in the book so the people in the book is about kind of kids in the future trying to learn about 80s culture oh i see and so one interesting side effect is that really happened in the present yes so like people right now are actually like learning about 80s culture to understand this book yeah so anyways check it out it's pretty meta i like it
读起来很有趣。酷，是啊，我绝对会读那本书。那么进入今天节目的编程语言。没错。我们今天有三种语言，Jython、Clojure 和 Scala。所有这些东西的共同点是它们是为使用 Java 虚拟机而编写的语言。所以 Java 虚拟机是 Java 运行的虚拟机。是的！
it was a fun read cool yeah i'll definitely read that so on to the programming languages of today's show that's right. We have three languages today, Jython, Clojure, and Scala. And all of these things have in common that they are languages written to use the Java virtual machine. So the Java virtual machine is the virtual machine that Java runs on. Yes!
我喜欢说这样的话。所以当你编写 Java 代码并运行 Java 编译器时，它会将其编译为字节码，然后在 Java 虚拟机上解释和运行，这在 90 年代 Java 刚出来时就是它的全部意义所在：一次编写，到处运行，永远运行。我的意思是，那里面有一些双关语。就像你写了代码，与 C++ 不同，你可能需要根据平台进行更改，
I love saying statements like that. So when you write Java code and you run the Java compiler, it compiles it to the bytecode, which gets interpreted and run on the Java virtual machine, which was kind of Java's whole thing when it came out in the 90s was write once, run everywhere, run forever. I mean, there was some play on that. It was like you wrote your code, as opposed to C++, where you might have to change based on your platform
并且了解 NDN 之类的东西。Java 就像，我只是要写一次代码，它就会到处运行。拿去运行就行了，一旦编译好，就可以使用了。DAN GALPIN——即使在更高的层面上，C++ 也没有真正触及 GUI 之类的东西。人们期望如果你想制作一个 GUI，一些用户
and know about NDN-ness and know about all this stuff. Java's like, I'm just going to write my code once, and it's going to run everywhere. Just take it and just run it, run it, run it, once it's compiled, it's good to go. DAN GALPIN- Even on a higher level, C++ didn't really touch things like GUI. It was expected that if you wanted to make a GUI, some user
界面，你必须挂钩到 Windows。DAN GALPIN——操作系统，无论你的操作系统是什么。DAN GALPIN——是啊，你必须向 Windows 或 Mac 或 Linux 请求一个窗口或按钮。你必须写三个版本，对吧？但有了 Java，他们为你做了所有那些艰苦的工作。所以他们写了三个版本的 GUI，并且为所有三个版本提供了一个通用的 API。
interface, that you would have to hook into Windows. DAN GALPIN- The OS, whatever your OS was. DAN GALPIN- Yeah, you'd have to ask Windows or Mac or Linux for a window or a button. And you'd have to write three versions, right? But with Java, they did all that hard work for you. So they wrote three versions of their GUI, and they had one common API for all three.
所以你可以拿走你在 Windows 上编写的 GUI 程序，并且知道它可以在 Mac 上运行。我的意思是，按钮可能会大一点。你可能需要做一点调整。但大多数情况下，他们处理了几乎所有事情。所以 JVM 为你买了很多。我们过去谈论过虚拟机。也许我们将来会重温它。
And so you can take some GUI program that you've written in Windows and just know that it will run on Mac. I mean, the buttons might be a little bigger. You might have to do a little bit of tweaking there. But for the most part, they've handled just about everything. So the JVM buys you a lot. We've talked about virtual machines in the past. Maybe we'll revisit it in the future.
但这个 JVM 的概念是一个定义的机器，但它实际上并不存在，或者它不必实际存在。它是一个被描述的理论机器，它编译成的字节码然后被解释和运行，就像在真实机器中执行指令和移动东西到寄存器一样，但然后虚拟机
But this idea of the JVM is a defined machine, but it doesn't actually exist, or it doesn't have to actually exist. It's a theoretical machine which is described, and the bytecode that it's compiled down to and then interpreted and run is just like in a real machine to be executed with instructions and moving stuff to registers, but then the virtual machine
将这些从它自己翻译到它正在运行的任何当前处理器上，这就是为什么你在 ARM 上运行并不重要，因为你向 Java 虚拟机发出相同的指令，然后 Java 虚拟机知道如何依次向它正在运行的 ARM 处理器发出正确的指令。这就是你获得“一次编写，到处运行”的方式。所以所有这些构建在 JVM 之上的语言
translates those from itself to whatever current processor it's running on, which is why it doesn't matter if you're running on ARM because you're issuing the Java virtual machine the same instructions, and then the Java virtual machine knows how to, in turn, issue the proper instructions to the ARM processor that it's running on. And so that's how you get that write once, run everywhere. And so all these languages that were built on top of that JVM
都免费获得了这些东西。而且就像 Jason 说的，也免费获得了内置的 GUI 东西、网络东西。无论为 Java 构建了什么，它们都免费获得了。是啊，甚至有些东西经常被忽视。但，例如，Java 有一个很棒的日期和时间库。所以你实际上可以说，时间是自纪元以来的这么多秒，或者那是人们通常使用的，UTC。
kind of get that stuff for free. And like Jason said, also get the built-in GUI stuff for free, networking stuff. Whatever is built for Java, they kind of get that for free. Yeah, even there's some things which kind of go unnoticed many times. But, for example, Java has an awesome date and time library. So you can actually say, the time is like this many seconds since the epoch, or that's what people usually use, UTC.
DAN GALPINIERI——等等，你发音是 epoch 吗？我总是发音为 epoch。DAN GALPINIERI——哦，到底是哪一个？我们得查一下。我想是 epoch。DAN GALPINIERI——我讲完这个想法，你可以查一下。但你可能有在希腊或荷兰的用户。
DAN GALPINIERI- Wait, do you pronounce that epoch? I always pronounce it epoch. DAN GALPINIERI- Oh, which one is it? We'll have to look it up. I think it's epoch. DAN GALPINIERI- I'll finish this thought, and you can look it up. But you might have users who are in Greece or in the Netherlands.
哦，你是对的。是 epoch。我以为那是愚蠢的。DAN GALPINIERI——是 epoch，是的。或者在荷兰或美国或英国，无论哪里。你可能希望他们看到时间，你知道，他们在时钟上看到的时间，对吧？
Oh, you're right. It is epoch. I thought it was stupid. DAN GALPINIERI- It's epoch, yes. Or in the Netherlands or the US or UK, whatever. You might want them to see the time, you know, that they're seeing on their clock, right?
而且你希望每个人都能看到适合他们的正确本地化时间。这实际上非常、非常难。你知道，我的意思是，它看起来超级容易，但你考虑一下，比如，即使在美国，比如，我们有夏令时，我们有所有这些其他问题，你有……你知道你有不同的……你知道时区，你有滚动，甚至还有一些非常古怪的事情可能会出现，比如我很难
And you want everyone to see the right localized time for them. That's actually really, really freaking hard. You know, I mean, it seems super easy, but you think about, like, even in the US, like, we have daily savings time, we have all these other issues, you have you know you have like you have different you know time zones you have rollover and there's even like really wacky things that can come up like i'm having trouble
想到……哦，比如一个例子是，假设你说……如果你购买这个产品，它在……到期。好吧，那是什么意思？那是指你当地时间的 12:01 吗？还是指 UTC 时间？所有这些东西都可能变得非常棘手。所以你必须把它弄对。但当 Java 能为你做这些时，这真的很好。JOHN MCCUTCHAN——或者至少那些也
thinking of off top of my head oh like one for example is let's say you you say um if you buy this product it expires you know on theth. Well, what does that mean? Does that mean 12.01 on your time, localized time? Or is it this time UTC? All this stuff can get really hairy. So you have to kind of get it right. But it's really nice when Java can do it for you. JOHN MCCUTCHAN- Or at least the stuff that also
内置在 Java 中，或者至少在 Java 虚拟机上运行的东西，为你做了这些。DAN GALPIN？是啊，完全正确。是的。所以我们正在谈论的是所有这些语言，它们不仅在 JVM 上运行，而且它们还可以原生使用所有的 Java 库。所以 Java GUI、Java DateTime，所有这些东西你都免费获得了，这非常令人惊叹。所以第一个是 Jython。
is built in Java, or at least to run on the Java virtual machine, does it for you. DAN GALPIN? Yeah, exactly. Yep. And so kind of what we're getting to is all of these languages, not only do they run on the JVM, but they also can natively use all of the Java libraries. So the Java GUI, the Java DateTime, all of this stuff you get for free, which is pretty amazing. So the first up is Jython.
是的。疯狂的名字。是啊，我的意思是，它看起来很狂野。没人会想到它是 Java 和 Python 放在一起。这真是太牵强了。等等，什么？是啊，这是列表上的 Java。
Yes. Crazy name. Yeah, I mean, it took pretty wild. No one would figure out that it was Java and Python put together. It's just such a stretch. Wait, what? Yeah, this is actually Java on the list.
所以是啊，Jython 是……所以关于 Jython 的一件事有点不同，当你谈论这个时你会感觉到一个梯度，Jython 非常像 Python。我的意思是，你实际上可以做 import Python import 语句并导入 Java 类来获得我们之前谈到的那些好处。但大多数情况下，你是在写 Python，而且很多人使用 Jython，或者抱歉，很多人用 Jython 编译常规 Python 脚本。所以他们只是写常规 Python 脚本。而且出于任何原因，平台，无论什么，他们宁愿在 JVM 上运行它们，而不是使用 Python 等价物。对。就像想象一下，你知道，你在 ARM 上。
So yeah, Jython is, so one thing about Jython that's kind of different, and you'll kind of sense a gradient when we talk about this, is Jython is very much Python. I mean, you can actually do import Python import statements and import Java classes to get those benefits that we talked about earlier. But for the most part, you're writing Python, and many people use Jython, or sorry, many people compile regular Python scripts with Jython. So they just write regular Python scripts. And for whatever reasons, platforms, whatever, they'd rather run them on the JVM than using the Python equivalent. Right. Like imagine if, you know, you're on ARM.
好吧，也许，我不确定 Python，你知道，虚拟机是否在 ARM 上编译。但假设你在某种疯狂的新架构上。你是一名硬件工程师。你制造了这个新处理器。它完全狂野。你的第一步是移植 JVM？当然。好的。
Well, maybe, I'm not sure if the Python, you know, virtual machine compiles on ARM. But let's say you're on some crazy new architecture. You're a hardware engineer. You made this new processor. It's totally wild. And your first step was to port the JVM? Of course. Okay.
那是你在 MAME 运行之后做的。第一步，MAME。第二步，JVM。我以为第一步是 Doom。每个人总是让 Doom 在所有东西上运行。好吧，是啊。其实，是啊，如果你让 SDL 运行，也就是 MAME 构建的基础，你就免费获得了 Doom，因为 Doom 也是基于 SDL 构建的。
That's what you do right after you get MAME running on it. Step one, MAME. Step two, JVM. I thought step one was Doom. Everybody always makes Doom run on everything. Well, yeah. Actually, yeah, if you get SDL running, which is the thing that MAME is built on, you get Doom for free because Doom is also built on SDL.
我需要重新安排我的生活。其实，我有一个朋友正在努力让 SDL 在 Boxy 上运行，一个已 root 的 Boxy。好的。总之，我们离题了。所以，你知道，另一件事是优化。比如 Guido 是一个超级聪明的人。他做了很多很酷的事情，但他可能，还有他的团队，以及在 Python VM 上工作的人可能没有像在 Java VM 上工作的人那样的资源。
I need to reprioritize my life. Actually, I have a friend who's working on getting SDL on the boxy, a rooted boxy. Okay. Anyways, we digress. So, you know, and the other thing is optimization. Like Guido is a super smart guy. He did a lot of cool stuff, but he probably, and his team, and people who work on the Python VM probably don't have the resources as the people who work on the Java VM.
所以 Java VM 刚刚有了疯狂的……而且关于人们用 Java VM 做的事情以使其变得更好，也有大量的研究和文献。它有许多不同的实现。有像 ICT 和 OpenJDK 版本。有 Suns。有等等。好吧，那是一个好点。是的，也有多个 JVM。是的。
So the Java VM has just had crazy, and there's also a ton of research and literature on things that people have done with the Java VM to make it a little bit better. There's many different implementations of it. There's like the ICT and the OpenJDK version. There's Suns. There's et cetera. Well, that's a good point. Yes, there are multiple JVMs as well. Yep.
所以Java虚拟机的发展非常疯狂，而且关于人们为了改进Java虚拟机所做的工作，也有大量的研究和文献。它有很多不同的实现版本。比如有ICT版本和OpenJDK版本。还有Sun公司的版本等等。嗯，这是一个很好的观点。是的，确实有多种JVM。
Yep, so that's a good point. I think we talked about that before. Yeah. multiple JVMs as well. Yep. Yep, so that's a good point. I think we talked about that before. But anybody who writes this layer to basically expose on the one hand an interface for the Java virtual machine spec and then on the other side runs on whatever architecture essentially can do their own JVM.
没错，这是一个很好的观点。我想我们之前讨论过。是的，还有多个JVM。没错，这是一个很好的观点。我想我们之前讨论过。但是任何编写这一层的人，一方面是为了暴露Java虚拟机规范的接口，另一方面是在任何架构上运行，本质上都可以实现他们自己的JVM。
Pending all the proper licensing agreements, whatever you're doing. Whatever that, you know, because Java is partially sort of kind of open sourced, I guess, right? So there's all sorts of policy issues. Because Java is partially sort of kind of open sourced, I guess, right? So there's all sorts of controversy in court cases, and we're not lawyers, so we won't say that. No, we're not lawyer cats.
这取决于所有适当的许可协议，无论你在做什么。无论那是什么，你知道，因为Java在某种程度上是开源的，我想，对吧？所以有各种各样的政策问题。因为Java在某种程度上是开源的，我想，对吧？所以有很多争议和法律案件，我们不是律师，所以我们不会那样说。不，我们不是律师。
But the other thing is, you know, a lot of mobile, like Android runs on Java. So in theory, Android can run Jython, Clojure, and Scala. I mean, I haven't tried it. I know for a fact it runs Scala. We'll talk about that in a little bit. Okay. But, yeah, so you just get it. I know for a fact it runs Scala. Oh, really? We'll talk about that in a little bit. Oh, okay.
但另一件事是，你知道，很多移动设备，比如Android运行在Java上。所以理论上，Android可以运行Jython、Clojure和Scala。我的意思是，我还没试过。但我确实知道它运行Scala。我们稍后会谈到这一点。好的。但是，是的，你只是得到了它。我确实知道它运行Scala。哦，真的吗？我们稍后会谈到这一点。哦，好的。
But yeah, so you just get a ton of stuff for free. So writing Python with Jython just gives you a ton of benefits, right? And almost no problems. I mean, that's good that if you don't have to change anything, you can always try it. Like if you're suffering a certain problem or want to run it, I mean, it's worth a try, right? Yeah. Especially if you're on a mal-supporter or not great-supported platform. Then you don't have a lot of risk to trying it is what it sounds like.
但是是的，你免费得到了大量的东西。所以用Jython编写Python会给你带来很多好处，对吧？而且几乎没有问题。我的意思是，如果你不需要改变任何东西，那很好，你总是可以尝试一下。比如如果你正遭受某个特定问题或想运行它，我的意思是，值得一试，对吧？是的。特别是如果你在一个支持较差或支持不太好的平台上。那么尝试它的风险并不大，听起来是这样。
Yeah, totally. So the second one is Clojure with a J. So I think similar to the story with Python, Jython. Wow. with Python, Jython, wow, similar to the story with Jython is having Python run on the Java virtual machine. Clojure is very similar. This is running Lisp on the virtual machine. And you get all those nice advantages that we've already discussed, rehashing.
是的，完全正确。所以第二个是Clojure，带一个J。所以我认为和Python、Jython的故事类似。哇。和Python、Jython，哇，和Jython的故事类似，就是让Python在Java虚拟机上运行。Clojure非常相似。这是在虚拟机上运行Lisp。你得到了我们已经讨论过的所有那些很好的优势，重申一下。
And you're able to intermix the niceness of a functional language like Lisp that that gets you and still have some of the use of the underlying Java libraries and JVM. This is kind of like one of those episodes of a show where they go back in time and visit all the old episodes. It's kind of like because of the way that we're talking about all these other languages. Oh, I see, because we're all talking about languages we talked about before. But, yeah, definitely, you know, if you haven't heard the Lisp show, give it a listen. But, you know, Lisp is awesome.
而且你能够将像Lisp这样的函数式语言的优点结合起来，同时仍然可以使用底层的Java库和JVM。这有点像那种回到过去访问所有旧剧集的节目。这有点像，因为我们正在谈论所有这些其他语言。哦，我明白了，因为我们都在谈论我们之前谈过的语言。但是，是的，绝对，你知道，如果你还没听过Lisp那期节目，去听听看。但是，你知道，Lisp很棒。
It does some amazing things. It has incredibly fast hash tables and it lets you use lambda expressions, all sorts of super fun stuff. But it's also very niche, right? I mean, there are things that you don't want to write in Lisp. You don't want to write, you know, like a file IO library in Lisp is like painful, right? So, you know, you can actually integrate, you can go seamlessly between Java and any of these languages. So you can take the part of your problem that you're trying to solve that's very easily solved by Lisp, and you can do that part in Lisp and then do the rest of your program in Java,
它做了一些了不起的事情。它有非常快的哈希表，它让你使用lambda表达式，各种超级有趣的东西。但它也非常小众，对吧？我的意思是，有些东西你不想用Lisp写。你不想写，你知道，比如在Lisp中写一个文件IO库是很痛苦的，对吧？所以，你知道，你实际上可以集成，你可以在Java和任何这些语言之间无缝切换。所以你可以把你试图解决的问题中很容易用Lisp解决的部分拿出来，用Lisp完成那部分，然后用Java完成程序的其余部分，
and they'll just communicate with each other, and it'll work very fluidly. The other thing is I think Clojure also adds some pretty advanced stuff. I think they add, like, a software transactional memory, which maybe we'll talk about in one episode. So they do add some things, and Lisp has all these dialects, I guess, or kind of what they're called. But Lisp has all these dialects, I guess, are kind of what they're called. But Lisp has all these dialects, and Clojure, I
它们会互相通信，而且会非常流畅地工作。另一件事是，我认为Clojure也增加了一些相当先进的东西。我想他们增加了，比如，软件事务内存，也许我们会在某一集中讨论它。所以他们确实增加了一些东西，而且Lisp有所有这些方言，我想，或者这就是它们被称为的那样。但是Lisp有所有这些方言，我想，这就是它们被称为的那样。但是Lisp有所有这些方言，而Clojure，我
don't know if you can consider one of them or not, but it does add its own set of flavor to what it kind of does better or different than the existing Lisp, in addition to all of the JVM advantages you get. And having a macros set up where you're able to call Java APIs from your Clojure code. DANis you know from your closure code yeah yeah totally i mean i did a lot of list programming in college and i never did anything with a gui like i there are times i wanted a gui but i just you know with lisp it's like if there was some way it'd probably
不知道你是否可以认为它是其中之一，但它确实为它比现有Lisp做得更好或不同的地方增加了自己的一套风格，除了你获得的所有JVM优势之外。并且有一个宏设置，你可以从你的Clojure代码中调用Java API。丹，你知道从你的Clojure代码中，是的，是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我在大学里做了很多Lisp编程，我从来没有做过任何GUI相关的东西，比如，有些时候我想要一个GUI，但我只是，你知道，用Lisp，如果有什么方法，它可能
be some lisp gtk like crazy hackery that probably wouldn't work half the time right and it's just it's kind of that stuff's super ugly, right? But, you know, the JVM has sort of taken a lot of that complexity away. So you could write, you know, a Clojure program that has like a GUI built into it and lets you like, you know, visualize results in a way that's more appealing. You know, and you'd have much higher productivity than if you're writing in straight lists. And I guess, I mean, I remembered a point during this discussion about that running on the JVM also brings this security. So when you run a C++ application, you don't know what that, you're basically letting that, aside from what the OS provides, you're letting that thing do whatever it wants to.
会是一些Lisp GTK之类的疯狂黑客手段，可能有一半时间都无法工作，对吧？而且那种东西超级丑，对吧？但是，你知道，JVM已经把很多那种复杂性去掉了。所以你可以写，你知道，一个内置GUI的Clojure程序，让你，你知道，以更吸引人的方式可视化结果。你知道，你会比直接用Lisp编写有高得多的生产力。我想，我的意思是，我记得在这次讨论中有一个观点，即在JVM上运行也带来了这种安全性。所以当你运行一个C++应用程序时，你不知道那个，你基本上是让那个东西，除了操作系统提供的之外，让它做任何它想做的事情。
But the JVM, barring recent exploits that were discovered, the JVM has this notion of security. So you're supposed to be able to run untrusted code. And if you don't want to let that code access the file system, it's not supposed to be able to break out of that virtual machine. So it's not supposed to be able to do stuff you don't want it to do. And so when you
但是JVM，除了最近发现的漏洞之外，JVM有这种安全性的概念。所以你应该能够运行不受信任的代码。如果你不想让该代码访问文件系统，它不应该能够跳出那个虚拟机。所以它不应该能够做你不想让它做的事情。所以当你
run Clojure, for instance, in the JVM, you're getting that added ability to kind of have that feeling of security. I mean, there are whole teams from many different, like, you know, multi-corporate, you know, consortia that are looking into JVM security. There's probably next to nobody looking into Lisp, you know, the C Lisp security, right? So yeah, you get the benefit of all these resources. So our final language is Scala. Scala takes a little bit of a different bent than these
运行Clojure，例如，在JVM中，你获得了那种额外的能力，可以有那种安全感。我的意思是，有来自许多不同，比如，你知道，多公司，你知道，财团的整个团队正在研究JVM安全性。可能几乎没有人研究Lisp，你知道，C Lisp安全性，对吧？所以是的，你获得了所有这些资源的好处。所以我们的最后一种语言是Scala。Scala采取了与这些稍微不同的倾向，
in that it doesn't port an existing language to the JVM or an existing language concept to the JVM. It instead tries to be kind of everything Java is, but even better. So it tries to be its own thing. And so some of the interesting things about Scala is that it's both functional and object-oriented. So you can kind of pick whatever you need
因为它没有将现有的语言移植到JVM，也没有将现有的语言概念移植到JVM。它反而试图成为Java所是的一切，甚至更好。所以它试图成为它自己的东西。所以关于Scala的一些有趣的事情是它既是函数式的又是面向对象的。所以你可以选择你需要的任何东西
from the strengths of both of those in your code. It gets all these benefits we've already talked about, about really good compatibility with the existing JVM. And the nice thing about Scala being a new language and kind of trying to extend upon the Java syntax is sometimes writing Scala code, you know, I'm doing air quotes here, is as simple as just making a very few modifications
从这两者的优势中提取到你的代码中。它获得了我们已经讨论过的所有这些好处，关于与现有JVM的真正良好的兼容性。而且Scala作为一种新语言，试图扩展Java语法的好处是，有时编写Scala代码，你知道，我在这里用引号表示，就像做极少数修改一样简单
to existing Java code. Right. And then once you do that, you may be able to do some concept that would have taken you many, many, many lines of Java code and it's just a few lines of Scala code. Yeah, I mean, anyone who's done, you know, raw Java on Android has been through the pain of runnables.
对现有的Java代码。没错。然后一旦你这样做了，你可能能够做一些概念，这些概念在Java中需要很多很多行代码，而在Scala中只需要几行代码。是的，我的意思是，任何在Android上做过原始Java的人都经历过runnable的痛苦。
So Java has this thing called runnable, and the idea is, you know, this is something that you want to run in another thread. So a runnable, you know, on the surface, a runnable just has, is just a class with a run function, so there's not much to that. But the idea is many of these thread, like a thread pool in Java or a single thread, if you want to kick off a thread, will take a runnable as a parameter and then
所以Java有这个叫做runnable的东西，想法是，你知道，这是你想在另一个线程中运行的东西。所以一个runnable，你知道，从表面上看，一个runnable只是一个带有run函数的类，所以没什么特别的。但是想法是许多这些线程，比如Java中的线程池或单个线程，如果你想启动一个线程，会接受一个runnable作为参数，然后
execute the run function in another thread. The thing about Android is Android doesn't want you to lock the OS. I mean they don't want you to do something that paralyzes the person's phone. And so they really encourage you to do everything in other threads. What this means is you have just tons of these runnable container classes that don't have any data in them.
在另一个线程中执行run函数。关于Android的事情是Android不想让你锁定操作系统。我的意思是他们不想让你做一些让人的手机瘫痪的事情。所以他们真的鼓励你在其他线程中做所有事情。这意味着你只是有大量的这些runnable容器类，里面没有任何数据。
They're just classes so that you can call a run function. And your code gets kind of ugly. It's very hard to write clean code this way. Well, Scala, because it has the option of being functional, sort of gets around this. Functions become objects, and you can just pass them around to different methods. You could pass a function around to the Android OS, and
它们只是类，这样你就可以调用一个run函数。你的代码变得有点丑陋。用这种方式写干净的代码非常困难。好吧，Scala，因为它有成为函数式的选项，某种程度上绕过了这一点。函数变成了对象，你可以把它们传递给不同的方法。你可以把一个函数传递给Android操作系统，并且
it'll run it. It just makes the code look cleaner. SETH LADDELL- So Scala is being used. The other thing about what functional programming gets you is it lends itself to distributed processing more readily, in many people's opinion, than object-oriented programming, for instance. And so you'll see there are a number of, well, for several of these, but for Scala in particular, a number of very highly distributed web apps that use it. So Twitter has come out and said that they use Scala, and they've actually been big contributors.
它会运行它。它只是让代码看起来更干净。塞思·拉德尔- 所以Scala正在被使用。关于函数式编程能给你带来什么的另一件事是，在许多人的观点中，它比面向对象编程更容易进行分布式处理。所以你会看到有许多，好吧，对于其中几个，但特别是对于Scala，有许多使用它的高度分布式的Web应用程序。所以Twitter已经出来说他们使用Scala，而且他们实际上一直是很大的贡献者。
They released a set of learning guides for Scala, if you're interested. So that's actually what they use for their new engineers. People who are experienced software engineers, but new to Scala, that's what they use to teach them. So that's a recommended source of learning. Foursquare is known to use specifically one of the web frameworks of Scala, the lift framework.
他们发布了一套Scala学习指南，如果你感兴趣的话。所以这实际上是他们为新工程师使用的东西。那些是有经验的软件工程师，但对Scala是新手的人，这就是他们用来教他们的东西。所以这是一个推荐的学习来源。Foursquare以专门使用Scala的Web框架之一，Lift框架而闻名。
And so I'm pretty sure they'll probably help out contributing to that as well. But that's something they've come out and said that they use. And those are something that there are web frameworks for other languages and stuff. But many of these JVM-based languages do seem to have a strong web framework presence or really good web frameworks that seem really well supported.
所以我很确定他们可能也会帮助贡献它。但那是他们已经出来说他们使用的东西。而且那些是其他语言也有Web框架之类的东西。但是许多这些基于JVM的语言似乎确实有很强的Web框架存在，或者有看起来支持得很好的优秀Web框架。
Yeah, I mean, one thing Java got extremely well was the whole web movement. Like, Java was essential to that. I mean, they started JSP. They had Tomcat, which is a fantastic web server container. And so anytime you can hook into Java, you can take advantage of all of this history. The other thing, in the last episode, we talked about Hadoop and HBase
是的，我的意思是，Java做得非常好的一件事是整个Web运动。比如，Java对那个至关重要。我的意思是，他们开始了JSP。他们有Tomcat，这是一个很棒的Web服务器容器。所以任何时候你可以连接到Java，你都可以利用所有这些历史。另一件事，在上一集中，我们谈到了Hadoop和HBase
and all of these libraries associated with big data. All of that is written in Java. But if you're using one of these languages, you naturally can hook into those. So you could write a Hadoop job that runs on 10,000 machines in Python or in Lisp or in Scala. I think that wraps it up for this show. I mean, three languages which are interesting.
以及所有这些与大数据相关的库。所有这些都是用Java编写的。但如果你正在使用这些语言中的一种，你自然可以连接到它们。所以你可以编写一个在10,000台机器上运行的Hadoop作业，用Python、Lisp或Scala。我想这为这个节目做了总结。我的意思是，三种有趣的语言。
Maybe that's a little bit of cheating because we kind of handled them together. Well, it encourages people to go and watch those shows. So if you haven't listened to the episode on Python, Lisp, or Scala is actually based on Scheme, which is probably something we'll cover in a future episode.
也许这有点作弊，因为我们把它们放在一起处理了。好吧，它鼓励人们去观看那些节目。所以如果你还没有听过关于Python、Lisp或Scala的节目，Scala实际上是基于Scheme的，这可能是我们未来一集中会涵盖的内容。
But yeah, check out those languages and check out those shows. Yeah, it's good times. Awesome. Well, I think that's a wrap. Cool. Have fun, everyone. The intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution uh to uh patrick and i and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但是是的，去看看那些语言，去看看那些节目。是的，那是美好的时光。太棒了。好吧，我想这就是结束了。酷。大家玩得开心。介绍音乐是biner pilot的axo，Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供署名，呃，给帕特里克和我，并且以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。